how do you put on a hoodie like a boomer
i don't know how you've managed to find
a way to do it it's a [ __ ] hoodie
you've worn a hoodie for chris oh my god
chris in a hoodie just looks like that
[ __ ] like hello fellow kids
hello everyone welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast i'm
your host for today joey and i'm with
the boys as per usual and we have a
familiar face
all right this is like the biggest
podcast in the world
there's black people moving the set
around while we're filming
you'll never get this from the lebron
japan studio
there's nobody
do you want to introduce yourself to our
audience chris it's your boy chris
your boyfriend it's your boy
am i cool now because i say your boy
yeah how are you doing guys good to see
you all welcome back for the fourth time
the fourth time the fourth one the big
one yeah the big one yeah big one
how you guys doing yeah doing all right
yeah
another episode of chris tries not to
get cancelled yeah yeah we've got 20
hours
we're gonna have to cut from this
episode
everything to play for i'm in a good
mood though i was recently in japan
times i was described as affable
i'm thinking of rebranding to affable in
japan but i'm not just half a boy name
i'm
in nature i don't know
what does it mean
it's somebody who's approachable
affable
approachable relatable why not just say
approachable approachable in japan like
a male karen i'm afraid and i've bought
christmas presents it's a little bit
late oh yes it's a february it's
february chris what are you doing
it's definitely not the 21st of december
we're filming this in i've been camping
out the front of the studio for a whole
month waiting to be allowed
my fault anyway did you wrap those
presents yourself oh my god you actually
wrapped them up i am laughable
what an hour who's got what the what's
this one
the other one
uh animation that's you that's
this year so we got you some drip chris
thank you very much guys trash taste
merchandise thank you so much
chris yeah a little bit later on in the
show
will it actually fit yeah
big size
i asked the man at the toy store what
all the kids want this christmas
and this was what he said yeah oh well
you picked her right because uh i've
always wanted this there you go it's the
mario kart
go card
that's actually a princess
you got batteries and i got batteries
is this the one that i played around in
your studio no it's not as expensive as
that one
it's the tube [ __ ] one you can drive
that around and uh drive acumen hell
yeah
this is a shared present with you in
sydney uh now you've got a new place
and uh
i figured thank you very much i thought
that was a bottle of wine i honestly
thought this was a bottle of water i
think god's got enough wine we've got a
yakitori you can enjoy that with your
wine thank you very much and uh
this will
be perfect in our new kitchen you look
like you're really forcing yourself to
say i don't know this will be uh
genuinely we've been looking for more
kitchen appliances
because we are
um we're experimenting with a lot of
cooking so thank you very nice
and uh
don't worry it's not it's not it's just
so heavy it's not a bomb don't worry
oh
that's a poker
for legal reasons we need to say we
don't obviously bet money on program
because gambling is illegal [ __ ]
heavy chips made up maybe next time you
can beat me at poker now you can
practice at home i'll feed you next time
wait he beat you a poker no i beat him
okay
i beat him as well i've been destroyed
he's rubbish
it was the night was going on long i'd
already collected all the money
let's just let's just let's just all or
nothing let's come on the night's over
and then chris won and then here now he
won't let me forget it
that's not what happened we went for two
hours it was eleven o'clock p.m at 11
p.m when we started yeah and connor was
winning for the first hour when he's
like what time his place closed what
time's open was that until one someone
will stay all night we'll play and he
did really well he was doing really well
to be fair he annihilated this poor
japanese twice twice and he bought back
in sheepishly got annihilated again i
was like oh
and then i was like bidding my time i
done quite badly and con was like come
on chris you got to step up your game
mate i i
thought chris didn't know how to play
poker for the first hour because you
just didn't do anything and then i had a
good time it was like ace king yeah yeah
and i was like plus a good hand and i
was like putting some chips like all in
i was like cool and connor was like
exactly like that and then i went well
he got he went nothing and then he lost
or he kind of like decimated his pile
yeah he's probably going home
what time is the first place this also
wasn't for money uh there's some there's
a lot of place in japan you can just
gamble yeah fake money which you can't
buy anything yeah it's like it's a show
so monopoly money then yeah i didn't i
didn't know that at the time i thought
we could get money or we couldn't get
money i thought you could like get
drinks or something with it yeah you
can't get anything like drink vouchers
and stuff yeah yeah i think now you can
get him because i think even drink
vouchers is not oh because there's a big
poker scene weirdly in japan there's a
bunch of poker places in uh shinjuku
around that area well i mean there was
talks there was talks of opening that
casino in yokohama right recently and
then the yokohama government was like um
no actually we need room for pachinko
machines yeah i think it would be good
for japan to get casinos i think
they can realize how [ __ ] pachinko is
yeah get rid of these noisy [ __ ]
places it's the worst
the day they introduce casinos in japan
is the day gacha dies yeah
or it levels up
depending on how you view it playing
cards remember your traditional king
it'll be like anime-wise
it's like what you mean you can win this
thing called money yeah chance machines
that doesn't make sense does that make
sense i'd like to imagine that all the
poker tables are themed after like the
yu-gi-oh arm things it's like
hit me up
it goes on the thing i would play poker
if i was keeping one of those
you don't win money you win life points
yeah how amazing is that you just change
life points for money
there's so much hypocrisy in japan with
that so if i don't understand how they
can be a big poker scene in japan if you
can't win money i just well i didn't
know that before i played i thought
we're going to walk out billionaires
the guy was like well done and he gave
me like some monopoly money can i can i
get a drink of this he's like no you
can't do anything get out that's why
you've won 1 million zimbabwe dollars
you are now a millionaire
i was pretty disappointed but i beat
connor and that was enough
for chris
the one that you guys went to which is
the same one that we went to i did take
you there yeah was uh like you get
monopoly it's like a like a block right
like a plastic block you get that you
can exchange back to play another round
of pokemon yeah right
so you win
yeah
so what you win is just the chance to
compete together yeah yeah
you get to it's like it's like a it's
like a play for free pass
basically
sorry do you have to pay to play in the
place yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so
you have to buy we paid like 40 bucks to
play thinking that maybe we could get a
drink or something yeah we didn't really
i mean it's too fair it's on us for not
knowing yeah but yeah no it's you you
can just play again in future if you
happen to go back to the same bar in the
exact same place and you remember to
bring your piece of paper that says you
had money which i did
i use it to beat joey
we started we started we started playing
pokemon he was like three times as many
chips as me it was because it was at the
beginning because it was like four
japanese men's uh all entire earnings
that i'd gotten then getting to chris
so you can't even exchange it for prizes
or anything like that at least at
pacheco you can exchange it yeah that's
what i was thinking right sure yeah
surely if you could do pachinko there
must be some weird work around where you
can you could if you wanted to but maybe
it's not worth it well that's what i'm
saying i think but i think the pachinko
one typically is in another building
right it is yeah yeah you cash in your
balls and then conveniently just around
the corner there's someone that wants to
buy your balls and that sounds really
wrong and i regret saying that now
and he'll
purchase yourself what a coincidence i
want those balls he's five hundred
dollars i actually need ball bearings
starting my own factory yeah pachinko is
a strange thing i hate cake yeah i feel
like it it's
it's so it's such a blight on the
countryside as well oh yeah yeah every
countryside in japan is like just
depressed there's nothing the business
is dying yeah except for the the palace
of pachinko though it's like it's like
the monte carlo casino in the middle of
the rice yeah well that's the thing it's
like you know that an aryan the inaka is
like really [ __ ] booming when it
comes economically because there's a
pachinko parlor in the middle and then
all the businesses surround the pachinko
it's really sad i i got like brag i've
got like the number one video on
pachinko right yeah and you watch it and
you just don't understand why people
play pachinko i i i made it and i just
don't get it can you play pachinko i
mean that
you know i've never felt like an irl
auto play game until i played pachinko
yeah exactly
you turn a knob and that's and that's it
is that gameplay does that count as
gameplay it's like it's like the subtle
like wrist moves oh it's places itself
it's brilliant in the video though i did
i'd natsuki and he was like he's
unprofessional he's a professional
player really and we gave him i think
like a thousand balls we had to see how
many could get in half an hour and to be
fair to him he did get like four
thousand and he kind of had a strategy
just just luck
it's a it's a 91 degree angle
90 degrees bollocks
but like why is like you know you just
get like wrist cramps after like 10
minutes of playing it's awful
i don't get it man yeah it's not fun i
don't i don't
understand the fascination i feel like
because it's the only form of gambling
they have so yeah it just works oh
gotcha
that's not gambling you don't win money
well you don't win one in pachinko
either right you do yeah you win prizes
win prizes yeah you're in money no you
can't win money
you could get money no
you could change the balls for money you
can't yeah you can only exchange for
prizes otherwise it becomes a legal
gambling
that's that's how that's how they get
around that's how they get around it
pachinko isn't technically gambling
because you can't win money you just win
prizes yeah which you can
expect yeah you can win you can win
prizes
you win prizes which you then exchange
for money i know in the building itself
you can exchange the prizes but i know
if you want money you have to go to the
other building right i miss it yeah so
you can in the building itself you can
get like a bag of crisps for 10 balls
but if you want to change the balls for
money you go to the other building i
always thought it was you get the balls
you exchange them for prizes and then
you go to another building and you
exchange the prizes for money
no i thought that's what i thought that
was the work around no i'm not certain
it's money
can we can we fact check this please the
debate
because either way there is some legal
loophole yeah there's a legal loophole
that is getting taken advantage of here
because if so it is illegal to play
pachinko for money in japan but there
are loopholes around japan strict
gambling laws some stemming from the
belief that the japanese must okay
well yeah
[Music]
it's illegal it's illegal to win prizes
directly from the game yeah but so
that's where the prize
i know you you can't get money but it's
a loser you couldn't get money what do
you want no no no no no no you can't get
money directly from the machines yeah i
know that's not what i was arguing i
said you can get money from it you just
go to the building outside
but that's where the loophole comes in
yeah yeah that was never in contention
so the basically if they if they bring
in a casino
so basically if they bring a casino to
japan they have to do the same thing
unless they change the laws yeah it's
like you win blackjack and you win a
teddy bear places have changed the laws
before it's not beyond comprehension i
think this is japan
basically you get the uh the amount of
like for example the receipt that says
that this is the amount that you get for
a certain token yeah so this token you
well actually you guys have all done the
cranking videos
don't make me talk about that bloody
crane game bollocks yeah
how much how much did you waste chris
i think how much is it five hundred
dollars you might just burn that for fun
i'm more fun to setting it on fire than
wasting my time trying to catch that
[ __ ] monkey this is a good uh
transition into what you think about
crane games [ __ ]
awful i hate it never again i don't i
cause i recently did it uh as well on
conor's channel and i i asked connor i
was like so how much stuff did chris win
he's like oh a bag of chips i was like
what no i want at least
two bags did he have arms yeah he won
two bags of chips and he won uh a
knock-off kettle and the reason was i
didn't cheat like connor i didn't ask
this stuff i'm not sorry could i have
some help
that's what you're supposed to do boring
i like to play by the rulebook
look what happened i'm a man of honor i
play by the rules i don't need help
they're not playing by honor why should
you yeah to be fair i did win though and
the woman i was like can i get my crisps
out and she had to like remove it from
the machine and she went yeah yeah sure
and then she just put it back on the
shelf
and i was standing there are you taking
me for a mug what's going on give me my
crisps and like a supervisor had to come
over and be like sorry sorry here's a
winner him his points
i watch the footage it's quite funny
because there's a big sign on the
machine that said if it gets stuck where
chris has got stuck that you win the
prize yeah and then he's put it back
bastards
it was awful there was like nothing fun
about it
yeah it's it's it's fun
up to like the first prize you win and
then you just kind of feel like a monkey
pressing buttons afterwards and i was
trying to get a monkey curious george or
something wasn't it yeah yeah curious
probably we just gave up on that like
the machine took my money as well so not
only did my prize get like put back on
the shelf even though i'd won it fairly
i put in like you know 100 just went up
in smoke i had to get a woman over to
try and get the money out and while she
was doing that i was still trying to
catch [ __ ] curious george above her
she was like digging through the machine
like trying to get my money out like a
indiana jones excavation [ __ ] i hate
crane games
everyone that plays crane games
especially hate conor for making me do
it never ever again
ever
it was a good arcade though that send
that one was my favorite one i think you
said japan i know yeah did it have the
best prizes no i genuinely think the
prizes were
uh
maybe the tighter one has the best ones
yeah i won i won the ramen maker the
[ __ ] kettles and it's just a kettle
well you put boiling water in there you
just put your noodles in and they're
like ramen kettles so it's just a cup
just like a bowl of but it's got like a
budget
knockoff of the nissan cup noodles
i mean honestly the favorite prize that
i got was my [ __ ] uh home ramen like
thai ramen they had they had instagram
that was like my favorite oh [ __ ] it's
cool just seeing the variation of
different machines that they have
the one there was one that was like a
balance board and uh
for a crane game so you move around with
your feet yeah choose where the crate is
oh that's pretty cool that's awful isn't
it you can't control this all right you
just cheat and get on the floor and move
it i can't think of any cool i guess
i want like aloe hand cream for 200
hello
i used one of the small ones and i was
like i'm putting 200 yen and i got this
like aloe hand cream isn't there a
better way to spend five hundred dollars
yeah of course there is i'm not doing it
for a smart financial decision
it's content for content
because people like you seeing you fail
chris yeah too fair you you crying at
curious george for 20 minutes
i love seeing you guys i think my blood
pressure went up that day
at one point i was like i was like in a
machine like [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and i
looked around there's like a little kid
just watching me
they're snare
that's so good because it was i was
probably my strongest performance as
well and i was absolutely murdering all
these machines yeah but that's the
dichotomy of chris just struggling for
his life to get a bag of crisps at that
point like you've done how many crank
game machines like you're a natural boy
you'd say that but the one that i did
with joey was by far the most difficult
oh really oh the shinjuku one was
[ __ ] so hard it was tough it was
tough
although i still got more than chris
would you would you say that there was
there is an actual technique to crane
games now that you've done it like i
figured i figured out a technique okay i
think
here's the thing i think
some machines the level of difficulty
isn't decided by the crane it's the size
of the item they put in yeah right there
are some things that like boxes like
some of the figure boxes right yeah
they're like just too big where they're
just no matter where you push them
they're gonna fall in yeah and once they
fall into like a
like it's just like
it's like you can't get it out yeah yeah
yeah and so it's kind of there's
something you've got to reset it yeah
otherwise it's not going to work and
that's what you're going to call the
staff and be like sumimasen help me yeah
i'm just supposed to sort of gradually
pick it up and nudge it slowly towards
the end
again like some boxes are so
big and so are not good at moving that
they'll just naturally just fall into
that the moment you start moving them
and they just hope that you give up yeah
i remember in my episode like i asked
the staff lady i was like is there like
a technique of any kind with any of
these and she's like oh like people who
are really good at it just like figure
out the physics and i'm like figure out
the thing cool i have to be a physicist
to figure this [ __ ] out amazing you can
maybe make a profit from it if you're
like yeah really good but it's just not
worth it like why would you do it yeah i
remember when i asked for advice in my
video so he so the guy like on the crane
like he tells me oh you got to get in
this position which was like the
position you you do to like before it
flips over so he easily gets into gets
into gets it into that position and then
he's just like okay so what you do after
you get in this position then he opens
the box and he goes
takes his hands and goes you just flip
it over and it goes in the hole and i'm
just like brilliant all i need to do is
[ __ ] just have a pair of keys and
push it over with my hands why didn't
you tell me before what an easy
technique
just i just get like ptsd just thinking
about it i i thought chris was like just
playing it out for the camera but he was
genuinely furious after the video he was
just angry there's something about
exchanging that amount of money and just
getting nothing yeah nothing in return
stuff yeah you did no you didn't get
what was what you got was worthless no
no i got i got maybe like at best 200
quid worth of stuff that's why i only
played rhythm games when i got arcades
because you know you get the experience
you pay for
massive helicopters ac30 going to take
connor away
finally back to wales
playing game yeah great game
drop him in the sea of wales the place i
just made up those videos come out way
more fun than they are to shoot that's
for sure it was really it was like what
four hour shoot yeah yeah it was just
not fun it was it was for the first like
hour and a half i thought i was like oh
this might be a decent video and then
like the rest of the video it's like you
just run out of energy yeah like i'm
just like what do i say about this what
what do i say pushing the same button
for like the thousands and the videos
aren't really fun they're really
nice and easy to watch
would you win ren or something with it
[Laughter]
one of my favorite clips of all time is
when he's getting confused about ram and
ram and then i explained to him that ram
is her sister so yeah what ram
is
[Music]
do we have a ram no we don't actually
well you never bought a room
are they from japan
no they're fantasy characters
they're from like
who made this up yeah
do you know any twins in real life no
because the only twins i know in real
life then
the names are hammy and sami
i don't know any twins that have like
rhyming names yeah i don't know i don't
have any of the rhyming names what's the
story of rick rick and roberto as well i
guess that makes more sense
yeah
we know we know yes i know stories
what's what is rem ram about what
where's that name of the show
rem and ram
yeah they're two maids and they're
demons
and uh they're very uh enjoyable
characters why do you like it so much
it's a good show why is it good
i like the characters
what do they do that make you think yes
they're very caring for the mink
it's like a son getting in trouble by
his dad it's like i'm asking reasonable
questions here like what's the
attraction
to watch the show because there's you
know there's a few scenes with this
specific character yeah ram is just very
endearing more so than most animated
very effortless
a show where you like commentate over
there just you watching like non-satoshi
con anime would be hilarious actually
just it's not perfect blue i'm not here
i already watched you see it's like low
hanging fruit i watched acura again for
the first time in years the other day
yeah that's a beautiful film yeah how
amazing i mean i i you know i know
actually
yeah
i was like feeling emotional watching it
i was like yes this is emotional
perfection this is like what everything
yeah it's amazing
like the animation is [ __ ] incredible
and that's why i need to i'm thinking
sort of to become you know like like the
anime man i want to i want to get into
anime i mean it's pretty realistic right
now there's a gap in the market there's
a gap in the market right why don't you
watch anime anymore
don't go into this
we've been into this before it's like
you don't watch it as much now
yeah pretty much so i could be the new
anime man please
please
yeah i'll crack open uh an australian
side of that christmas
open now all right chris brought some
australian three oaks he brought some
three oak cider
these are actually pretty good they're
better on top but seeing a good job
changing subject isn't he all right
cheers
sorry don't worry chris okay i'll get
you into anime
yeah these two these two are posers i'm
i'm under i'm the real anime fan who's
the most who is the most anime man here
the anime that he'll recommend you will
bore you to death yeah
they're all reincarnation stories a
[ __ ] flowchart figure out what's
going on
so you know i did watch your anime and
review video i think it's been like two
or three weeks ago where you sort of had
like your lineup of things you
recommended watching yeah because i was
like i know i want to learn about anime
yeah i mean i i mean
i can't take you seriously
i'm not joking
i want to learn about animals
it's like it's like it's like my dad's
like my dad is like yeah
he's the voice of reason
incredible he's the voice of reasons and
i thought if i want to learn about anime
yeah
i mean you're already he's an anime
right
like you like satoshi khan and akira
yeah i love them that's anime but i mean
just by watching like four films does
make me like into anime but there's a
lot of shows that are like that in the
same vein that i reckon he'd get into
goes to the shell i mean there's there's
no one there
again like i'm not saying it's like
exactly the same or better but like you
know it's kind of in the same same vibe
yeah it's the same vibe yeah but i i you
know i i feel like i've neglected anime
the reason i don't watch anime just
because growing up i didn't know anyone
that watched it and right there was no
sort of you know they had like a bad
connotation as well to watch anime to be
like a little bit yeah certainly in the
uk i think it's seen as like a very
geeky losery thing i think everywhere
um
but i mean it's a lot different now like
you know we've said multiple times like
you know i think when we were growing up
like our age group you'd get bullied for
watching oh [ __ ] yeah but nowadays you
get bullied nowadays kids yeah only for
breathing
nowadays kids get bullied for not
watching anime yeah not watching certain
things that's not something popular
right
now yeah yeah
all the popular kids like i love
narrative based on your filmography
oh yeah but no i i do want to
investigate a bit further investigate it
you're saying this as if you're like
my toes into this anime
what do you recommend well based on what
i know and like like goes to the shell
acura satoshi com feed that into
yes of course you know like the iceberg
means
not the live action
i think he's watching like the the best
of the best yeah yeah degenerate i think
yeah yeah that's how you get someone
into anime i think you'd really enjoy
baccano
that's like a good entry-level tv series
what happens
okay so it's kind of like hard to
explain one sentence all right it's kind
of like a quentin tarantino guy richie
film turned into an anime that's good
that's a good synopsis yeah good little
line to get me in yeah actually any
anything anything that the organ makes
is kind of like that right like
also yeah that was a much like more
exciting description than what he said
about rem ramen well no no
i don't think you're like zero i i have
a i have a suspicion you might not like
greece yeah you're not gonna like racism
she's enduring oh brilliant i don't i
don't want endearing i want i want
tarantino they're not even the main
characters this is the funniest thing oh
really yeah who's the main character
that is actually a character yeah
that is a character there isn't like a
predict anime
you might like
what okay what films what films do you
like
something sci-fi gritty a bit of
something dark some sort of neo noise oh
psychopaths it's psychos
yeah the [ __ ]
everyone says i would like cowboy
beatbox i think you'd like cowboy should
i watch it on netflix
so so there's two versions of cowboy on
netflix
go for the anime
[Laughter]
yeah i think you really like cowboy
bebop and uh yeah psychopaths i think
psychopath
dystopian future where you're rated
based on your mental health score sounds
like real life
dystopian futures now well there it's
like it's like there's a there's a an
all-knowing algorithm that knows your
mental health stability and if you're
like psychotic it just kills you right
yeah so it's kind of like that's pretty
[ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah it's a [ __ ]
up show that's pretty exciting yeah and
of course who's going to do the killing
but these enforcers and it's a pretty
harsh story where you follow these
enforcers having to like basically
murder people and uh it's really [ __ ]
cool yeah it's it's really easy
it's really good actually they have they
have this gun right they have this gun
uh and you point at the person and the
gun scans what their mental health is
and if they're meant to help their
mental yeah if they're mental that the
gun goes from just you know stun gun to
just obliterating a person to like to
the atoms based on how bad their mental
health is not called against like
annihilators dominating almost like a
future where the dislike button was
never hidden then
because now it's gone my mental health
is so much better on youtube
but that's that's that's a cool premise
yeah it's a very cool phrase
psycho pass psychopaths i actually think
you'd enjoy that actually because if
you're a psyche pass
i think i think it's more the opposite
if you're a psycho you don't pass psycho
die
psycho
little really holden
out the times now
you should start titling anime psycho
die ram and ram yeah ram and ram and ram
all right i'll get into i would probably
enjoy it more than a new matrix that you
were talking about yeah yeah more into
general like films right and yeah and
cinematography and staying up with the
news and stuff but i think a lot of the
best cinematography comes out of anime
films just watching acura the other day
i was like holy [ __ ] the cinematography
this oh yeah it's brilliant the best of
the best 10 out of 10. so i kind of want
to go
down the anime rabbit hole yeah i mean
like did you explore them a bit more do
you still like look at films the same
way now or do you focus more on like
cinematography and just
the general filmmaking craft i still
think i i do look at cinematography a
lot but i still think story is really
important like i just watched the matrix
four yeah
resurrections and it was all right it's
very meta it kind of comments on itself
a lot and uh i recommend watching it
but it's there's no sort of replay value
i asked myself a film is good
is it if the film is good i want to
rewatch it yeah if i don't want to
re-watch it i can't say re-watch it if i
don't want to re-watch it then it's it's
not overly great
i think you'd like one punch man weirdly
enough one punch man i think he'd like
it i don't know i think he'd like it
really i think so i think anyone can
enjoy one point i think he'd i think
he'd find it amusing
yeah and i'd too fair the cinematography
is what i'm saying but there's a point
but i think there'll come a point where
he'll watch part one punch man and be
like oh this joke again
i mean i think i think you'd enjoy it i
don't think it would be like your
favorite most favorite answer right now
it's good like popcorn entertainment
yeah
because i remember this weekend i saw i
finally saw dune
not in cinemas unfortunately so i didn't
i didn't oh no i didn't feel the
subwoofers
you didn't feel the voice oh my god like
even
even being even watching it on my tv i
felt like like i felt like it was
getting bass out of the tv that just
didn't exist man well i think i i don't
know how it was playing a sub woofer
wasn't that great 300 tv i know because
you have the same one that would not
work i watched that imac so i nearly
cried it was like
bleeding
like han zimmer but like that was pretty
good but i got like the cinematography
and that was [ __ ] insane
duna's one is as good if dune two comes
out and if it's good and he's coming out
right yeah
i mean is it gonna be good i mean the
doom was amazing if dune two is good
because like it was weird because it
didn't feel like i was watching a movie
it felt like i was watching a hbo tv
series or something like that i did like
when it ended it felt like it was an end
of an episode rather than just an end of
the movie right but it wasn't
necessarily but i didn't really like the
ending and i hate
oh i don't know if it spoils it but just
by saying the last line the film when
she's like this is just the beginning
that's like there's a storm coming
that's sort of like [ __ ] line you see in
so many films i mean to be fair this is
based on the 60s book
how much seven eight out of 10.
eight point five i give it like an eight
or nine because the story just picks up
from there as well like if you wrote the
books but yeah i mean i'm looking for it
was just like my kind of story where it
just set up the world really well i was
more interested like i i watched i
watched the film and then i just went on
the binge of just lore explanation
videos because i'm just like there are
so many interesting aspects of this
world that they just kind of didn't have
time to explore yeah frank herbert was
nuts dude i don't know how he did it
yeah well it's it's like how old's the
book now like [ __ ] well first book
was 1964.
yeah
can i spoil one thing in it can we do a
spoiler warning okay
one thing i really didn't like about the
film is that they had this really uh
so again spoilers please please watch
dune please if you haven't um this is
really uh especially especially like a
really impactful scene where he kills
someone oh the first time it was very
good but then like it's supposed to be a
really big deal but they just like bring
it up like one second before he kills
someone for the first time they're like
by the way he's never killed anyone stop
stabbing a man to death and it's like oh
i
don't really think that was that
difficult it's yeah it's about to climb
i wish they'd like
because the big set piece has happened
sort of halfway through rather than at
the end yeah and i felt a little bit i'm
all for changing up the sort of story
and doing something a little bit
original but yeah i felt like the payoff
of the ending was like oh well i don't
think you think it needed a big set
piece that wasn't the highlight for me
because actually i was so immersed in
the world that when it went to the big
set piece i was like can we just go back
to doing like small [ __ ] yeah like i
just i just oh yeah i love that yeah
political the political aspect is really
yeah one of those films that i was like
bored for the first 40 minutes and then
after i'd kind of sat through all the
good stuff i was like actually now i
want more of the starting start board
more talking i wonder that's why when
you're making it is it hard to see it
from a perspective of someone who
doesn't know anything about the law of
dune how do you do it when you already
know so much about it and you know how
good the law is and how do you explain
it in a way that's engaging because i do
think i don't know if you were but i was
bored for the first 40 minutes just
waiting for something to happen i was no
i wasn't yeah the
world was pretty engrossing yeah yeah it
kind of reminded me of uh gonna mention
it again joey arcane where the first the
first two episodes nothing really
technically i want chris to watch that
actually he'd love it what's that about
oh you should summarize that
[Laughter]
if you go to if you go to that side i'm
i'm i'm truly alone have we gone a week
without mentioning no i actually i
legitimately can i legitimately want
someone to make one of those things
where it's like it's been blank days
since arcane was mentioned i just rip it
off every week it's amazing it's amazing
amazing [ __ ] i haven't seen it
yeah yeah amazing it wasn't it like one
of the top shows of imdb what's it about
how would you explain khan you're
clearly voting in one sentence legal
agency against one sentence
there's no way i can just display any
describe in one sentence
it's just a very engrossing world that's
kind of
kind of like say what it is it's league
of legends it's league of legends it's
based off of the game
not really no no no no no i know i know
i know right of shadows again
it's not it's not just give it a watch
give it a chance the animation is insane
how would you describe dune in the
sentence out of curiosity
[Laughter]
very good
imagine star wars but good
i love star wars but there's only two
films in the series they're good the
first one the second one that came out
in 1990 1977 and 19. wait 80. oh
four and five yeah yeah you say first
and second
one
i was like crap jesus christ dude i love
the first and second film or the prequel
memes oh yeah they're pretty good three
things
are the best memes the third one's all
right but like yeah june is like imagine
star wars but good i actually agree with
you i like the characters really not a
fan of star wars at all you know the
best thing about star wars was the lego
games that was the best thing about star
wars
[Music]
they were [ __ ] amazing
i don't play all of them but like the
first one was so good i remember i had
the act uh i think it was four to six
movies yeah yeah you did like the
trilogy and i was my only experience for
the movies for like the first 10 years
of my life and i used to [ __ ] love it
just love getting this [ __ ] i think
the only the only thing i liked about uh
episode one was the pod racing scene gal
yeah now this is the worst part no not
the last
lifesaver
let's just stop let's just stop talking
about star wars we clearly don't know
our [ __ ]
that's from a normal perspective i
thought it was all right i think the
problem was i you know i did like star
wars a lot then the new films came out
and destroyed everything and it was just
i haven't seen anything this is so
[ __ ] boring that's rogue one that was
uh right that's all right i quite like
it because that's sort of i mean if
you're a fan of the original star wars
film ties in nicely and the cat i didn't
care about the characters when they died
i was like
darth vader isn't it so it's good isn't
it
there's some cool scenes in it that call
back to the original and i like that but
like the new film's just just [ __ ] no
the characters i thought thought the
first film had potential and then it
just lacked a coherent direction i
thought well they just got made up as
they went along yeah that's what i felt
like
what's that chinese whisper game you
write a line fold it and move it on it
was like that yeah
you want ryan johnson i love ryan
johnson but like yeah but no there was
no coherent strategy yeah he was never
going to please what the fans wanted
they had they had such lofty
expectations
well it's just funny pedal didn't they
and then the last one they were like
just do whatever the fans want and it
was just really really bad that's
because nothing was set up yeah
everything was set up ryan johnson like
tore it down did his own thing and then
they were like well no that would have
worked though if they'd had another
follow-up to that mate yeah yeah
it wasn't yeah it's like i i think
definitely the second film
depended on the third film following on
from what he had set up but obviously i
mean it was just telling that like i
remember how much hype there was for
episode seven like yeah it was [ __ ]
everywhere seven was pretty well
received people were lost yeah yeah and
then of course but then like
but then every subsequent film there's
just less and less talk about it right
everyone's like oh no
i don't know and i didn't hear anything
about nine yeah number eight because
they set up eight so badly right yeah
carrie fisher the uh she
did princess leia flew through space
yeah
the spaceship went to lightspeed and
just like [ __ ]
kamikazed its way through another like
death star
it wasn't a death star i don't know what
the name of the ship is
destroyer
i could feel like the star wars fan just
like perk up when i said death star
but the worst bit
was the like the opening like five
minutes i knew it was [ __ ] yeah
because there's a scene i don't know if
you've seen it but like there's a your
mum joke in it are you serious yeah yeah
yeah there's like the main villains
there and he's like destroy the planet
and this guy's like got a message for
your mum and it's i'm not you're [ __ ]
making this up go and watch it and i was
like is that episode seven they tried to
get like that marvelous humor
in
and it just ruined everything so it's
[ __ ] it's those interesting
one-liners and it's like i've got a
message for your mum i'm not making this
i could have written that in the script
and it's just so bad oh what do you
think about them using actors that are
like they've passed away and they're
just like putting them in the films
uh as long as it's done tastefully i
don't mind it it's not weird about it
though isn't there i mean when you die
i'm gonna use you
cgi seed even if they're like yeah keep
using me i think it's just strange that
you're i mean i feel like it's it
depends on the manner that it's done i
mean there's a difference between
putting a beloved character in their
beloved franchise again as like a cameo
or something um and then there's using a
dead man's twitter to promote an nft
that's you know
i just feel like disney is not the
company you want being in charge of when
dead people can keep being in films yeah
yeah like i feel like dizzy's gonna be
like no
harrison ford hasn't died yet
he's gonna keep still alive and well
look at him we have a signed note that
says he wants to keep being in star wars
infinitely
he's got a signature on it we have the
estate of harrison ford agreeing that we
wanted him being hide solo for life
you can tell immediately though when
it's done in like a milking manner
though and like
fans fans are immediately i think i i
feel most fans immediately can recognize
they're like yeah that's a thing i
worked in one i think with
become like a common thing that is like
used very often
yeah
do you feel like it would get a little
weird when have you seen it and thought
no this is not good it's not that i've
seen it and it's not good i'm like oh no
people are going to take this too far at
some point like just make a whole film
with a man who's dead because their
their state
said sure it's like
it will happen i know it will
that's why it's kind of
i mean the music industry is already
[ __ ] there like all these [ __ ]
posthumous albums that it's horrible how
would you feel though like you know 10
15 years if you die
and then you're the connor only 10 15.
his cholesterol is pretty bad
as we've seen the connor estates like we
want to keep connors
connor would have loved to have been in
more videos in crane something
there's something sad about art when you
just have to bring people back from the
dead to keep making it you know what i
mean like there's something like why
can't we just just get into the talent
have art just continue to blossom with
new generations how i feel about the
matrix form
but uh but obviously it's when
corporations know that they can keep you
know because they're already trying to
rehash as much as they can the last
thing i want is that they can get the
rights to people's likeness and then
just start reproducing filled with them
well then i don't i don't think i'll be
commercially successful i i think if
someone does like go all the way then no
one's going to [ __ ] watch it
right or or they'll be just ridiculous i
feel like the industry said that about
so many things in our life and here we
are and you know
i don't know i feel i i don't know i
would like to i would like to grasp hope
and think that you know
grasp of the hope that you know maybe if
people have the right to agree in some
ways but then nft's existing
find i thought i thought it was a parody
account who posted it on his account his
family or something
he's going back into the
into stanley's twitter this isn't the
first thing that that twitter account
has promoted so obviously someone got
him to sign some [ __ ] documents
before he passed away right just giving
them rights to basically everything
because you can control some of the
state sure yeah so you can be in control
of everything basically yeah
it's pretty
yeah it's pretty fun
it's pretty [ __ ] you know what's like
what's next like stanley like deep fakes
where you
when he promotes like the newest crypto
coin
or he's at your local con
[Laughter]
jesus christ yeah it is getting very uh
very black mirror-esque you know this is
yeah this is some [ __ ] you'd see in a
black mirror episode except it's
unfortunately happening in real life i
mean i i think in our lifetime there'll
be technology where they could go
through every video we've made and
create an avatar digital avatar of us
that looks and sounds like us has the
same things
yeah but like i already have a full ai
sort of synthesized version of say
connor right so you sent ai to watch
every sea dog vehicle video god forbid
listen to all the podcasts you can get
his voice you can get his mannerisms his
personality and create a sort of aic
have you not heard the gone ai voice
what what
it exists already i haven't even heard
that you haven't heard it no no oh my
god we're already there
20 years ahead of schedule
the feature is now chris the future is
now
the title of the podcast episode
the future is now
chris thought he was you know making a
making a picture
what is this website then
i don't know how the i don't know what
the ethical requirements are to use
god's voice and give permission for this
oh my god
[Music]
we have
hours and hours and hours of audio from
us yeah wait are you guys on there no
i'm not why am i on there wait am i on
there
uh no oh okay
specifically me
you have the least amount of videos out
of all three of us
we've all talked an equal amount of
trash too yeah so
with just a phone strap to it with
john's face on it
that's terrifying isn't it the year the
year is 2030 all of trash taste episodes
are now auto-generated
you like bone-in shits what the [ __ ]
bidet
like one of my videos i made like a ai
system that could auto generate some
um anime and light novel titles and it
got to the point
these boys couldn't tell the difference
that's psychopaths
something like that right
or something like that
um and now they've uh released like
newer updated ai they could not only
make titles but actually write a full-on
like writing prompt like start like
write a first chapter of a story it's
pretty so it's all getting like pretty
insane jesus yeah and uh can i get it
working with this voice
jesus christ
why
who else is on there there's quite a lot
of youtubers on here really i love it
you've made it really i don't have to
you're ai now i don't have to record an
anime review again in my life
no no no no no it's america
i can link up with the script ai
and just make a video yeah exactly right
let's put this on do a phone call to
sydney and see if she can just determine
the difference
hold on it's synthesizing okay
synthesis
okay
oh god
it's like it's a it's a program i wrote
it there we go all right i love cruising
a man
i heard what he said what do you say
that doesn't need to be repeated
i love cruiser brodin a man
[Laughter]
i love chris that [ __ ] sounded gone
yeah i love chris
well it also depends on uh
how much reference they have because
they have like a spongebob voice that i
swear to god it's like a hundred percent
accurate really yeah jesus
they have chills as well and it's really
spot-on oh
[Music]
the last thing you want in your version
they went too far
[ __ ] you know i hope i'm back on that
channel one day we'll have to do
something scary that's the biggest honor
when chill sees your youtube channel i
think that that [ __ ] shipyard into is
scary enough shipyard
awful should be on it it was a shipyard
there's a connor a branch touched
conor's legs it's a streak i swear it
runs off something ran over my leg you
can watch the video slow it down you see
it's a twig he's like oh gosh there's a
snake or something you can't see it's a
[ __ ] twist
christian wants me to be a little [ __ ]
and then there's a spider
this
is awful
[Laughter]
right don't go in there you know we did
actually go to one there was like no
entry
yeah
yeah so be careful with him don't enter
but it doesn't say don't film
that's the pachinko loophole right
i figured if there's no sign saying you
can't go in and it's
publicly accessible i mean yeah
there was no wall or anything we didn't
like climb a fence literally just like
you you're on a road you just there's
like a patch of grass you walk into the
grass and you're there yeah so chris
it's been it's been a good year for you
you'd say somebody made a lot of videos
well somebody sent me a message being
like on the trash taste podcast at the
start of the year your like um new
year's resolution was to do something
crazy and wacky and you got the studio
and you met came out today yeah so kind
of pretty crazy i'm pretty happy with
other years
wanna do a six-part travel series with
gone called take him for granted
have you been like writing these jokes
writing them all down i'm just a genius
and i prepared that three months ago
he's been waiting to say that i can't
tell i want to abuse gantt through
physical activity
i wanna like climb krakatoa with god i
wanna go to crack it's like
you know just still like crazy like
chris using my body taking me to wanker
sober
it's got the video demonetised
it's awful
that's not that doesn't sound like a
dish it sounds like something you do
every night like
an awful experience
is is that how it's pronounced or is
that just how it goes it's not it's just
him
he's still wank in there
yeah because uh we went to uh we went to
a bar with jan the other day and he goes
chris just made me eat wank sober and
i'm just like
[ __ ] sober what's going on oh [ __ ] that
was highest
it was good too much
but i was like why do i have to ruin my
body for your [ __ ] channel chris how
about how about we run ruin my body for
my channel
yeah i did i you know
ptsd high blood pressure and then like
they did a fairy was like oh there's a
very it's really good we're not affair
of [ __ ]
i got really seasick and i had to like
lie down the entire shoot otherwise i
stood up i was like
that was also a horrible move at least
my videos they're like fun oh yeah yeah
going to an abandoned shipyard at 1am
freezing cold you wouldn't want to do
that
do you want to go to the abandoned
shipyard yeah
take it for granted it's coming soon
how long does it take you to think of
the
name wacky weekends what what that guy
was like
i said it was a joke i was like could
you think of a better one we do
something like wacky on a weekend
probably around the same amount of time
the anime man to be formed
as in five seconds nothing else worked
though that was snappy
yeah
wonderful wonder weekend wicked weekend
chris and connor i think rocky weekend
the chris and connor show chris and
connor abroad in japan
yeah he [ __ ] killed me on the bridge
as well that bridge was so dangerous
that was actually so dangerous
it was pretty fun that was pretty ropey
this poor kid nearly died on that bridge
went to that the worst hotel in japan i
still actually
i think that is the worst thing i've
done this year i've done a lot of
horrible [ __ ] but like like the cessna
over an active volcano but like this
hotel room we went to i i still can't
get the smell of that room out my head
and like i wish you were there because
you should have seen like the three
hours of chris just being like we should
we've got to stay haven't we and i'm
like no if you watch the video you can
see our eyes go red over the period of
the shoot because the air is just filled
with like 48 kinds of holes
you know
obviously we'd already paid for the room
but it was such a state where i was like
could you get another cheap hotel that
isn't bad yeah because you know why why
why stay here yeah and and chris was
just like i think we should stay here
i'm like for what reason chris
well even though i was dying there's
something still awkward about going down
to a hotel desk after two hours be like
oh we gotta go now bye it's not that
chris was worried about the content we
already got the content we filmed the
room chris was like he just didn't want
to go and confront the staff that we
were checking out all right and i was
like i'll [ __ ] do this like no we
can't do that it's rude
man of honor
and like all their clientele here are
checking out after one hour why do you
think that is
that's true yeah
people were coming and going well i
discovered that night we did you know we
showed you that was in the air
there was blood on the wall as well
there was blood on the wall that under
the giant blood stain on his mattress
they hadn't heathered under the bed they
just hovered around the bed and if you
lifted the beds in the videos massive
piles of dust massive layers like how is
it still in operation
i
[Music]
let me try to check into another hotel
in japan we discovered that it's really
hard to check into a hotel past sort of
eleven twelve years yeah yeah and the
staff are really angry at this nice
hotel we tried to get in they were like
what do you want a room no we can't do
it and then they were just like being
really dicks about it yeah we were like
we have a room with two beds and they
were like no we don't have one then
we're like how about two rooms with one
bed and they were like
okay that's that's yeah yeah wow yeah it
was like all right well i guess we won't
pay you then i guess which now is very
strange i understand it's pretty
inconvenience but what yeah definitely i
mean you're in the service industry yeah
literally yeah
was more affable than the people at the
four-star hotel and that's the irony i
thought this was actually quite nice
they were like oh my god people are
actually staying here oh my god money
what the [ __ ]
a customer there's a really sketchy area
as well yeah it's very seedy
well you don't have a hotel like that in
a [ __ ] uptown area do you yeah yeah
but it's so hard to talk about this
without sounding like a [ __ ] snob but
it was really just awful it was so bad
well i mean it's the worst hotel right
of course you're not going to be like
yeah it was lovely it was a common wall
it was the worst so something like that
in the comments though you've got a roof
over your head it's more than most and
it's like [ __ ] off mate this roof over
my head's going to kill me in one hour
[ __ ] off
hotel room and actively like worried
about my physical health yeah yeah you
know that's that's quite a weird
sensation to good i was googling like
how many types of mold are there and i
was like going around the room spotting
or
if there's mold in the room you should
probably leave as soon as possible but
that the kicker was like when connor
pulled the blanket back it was just a
big patch of blood on my bed but
i was like oh it's time to go like you
can't see you can't sleep in a pool look
like either somebody was stabbed and
they were bleeding on the bed or someone
missed the time of month i think yeah it
looks like that
yikes it was um either way no thank you
because yeah that i would also get out
take it for granted are you
did you ready it huh did i find that
hotel or did you find it uh i can't
remember i don't know i remember i found
out
in my head like a neuralizer for men in
black
the only evidence is that video i don't
want to remember that we found a ton of
hotels in chicago that looked really bad
like really really rough hotels but
because i think no one stays there but
i'm gonna see some trash day specials
next year will you guys
go in those sort of places
why those places
we've got to do exciting
i i had a massage recently a hotel and
uh i don't know
what a segway
there is a segway right
it was like my birthday
earlier this year and i went for a
massage
you said waterboarded right they put a t
they put a tea towel over my face i put
a tea towel in my face then covered me
in tea
and it was like this is waterboarding
isn't it numbers what do they mean chris
they like this towel on my face where
it's like liquid pouring down
and then she was like
i'm like
the room number what's the room number
yeah
it's a rifle my god just be careful you
get a massage in japan
what kind of massage oh god i i was a t
it was a team team
blankets
experience ever it was um i went it's
one go-to and it was included in the
hotel i thought why not i've never gone
for massage before okay why not what
could go wrong
so you know i'm face down on this
massage table you know it's already
quite awkward she's really like sheepish
about everything and then you know and
struggling to like explain to me to take
off my shirt and whatnot yeah oh okay
yeah
i lie down and i'm like chilling and
then i feel like
i hear like she's just like she's
preparing like oils and stuff and then
just smashing like splash breaking
and then i'm like awkwardly like what's
going on and then she's trying to like
stealthily pick up this glasses if she
hadn't broke it like like a whole lot i
had to realize right and i could just
hear her like every now and then i could
just hear a little like
and i'm just like it's okay just get the
[ __ ] broom it's already too late
like what are you gonna say you've got a
glass massage yeah it's like a
shatters of bottles over your head
inside the realms of possibility people
i experienced she was so walking she's
like 40 minutes of this poor woman
trying to pick up this uh this class and
i was just like just go at it i don't
give a [ __ ] it's already the ambiance
sorry ruined you want a massage in japan
girl i am not a fan of massages
but that's because like i'm used to thai
massages where oh right it's like just
like beat the [ __ ] out of you i'm not a
fan that's my first time and i don't
think i want another one yeah okay
i don't mind massages but i'm usually
not that stiff
so
i don't really
i don't really need a massage
oh good
god great anime man when you get your
haircut here sometimes they just start
massaging you it's really [ __ ] weird
yeah yeah yeah like it's okay i didn't i
didn't pay for that yeah i i'm like
because i'm like 10 in my head i laugh
they're like they're like
i'm like
japanese service like
beyond extra it's like you don't need a
massage or you're getting your hair cut
yeah it's just the weirdest ones is when
they're like shampooing you and then
they start massaging your head yeah
yeah i like that i got natsuki did that
to me once i just felt really
uncomfortable
because a
[Laughter]
i think i think the weirdest place i got
a massage was i was staying in this like
high-class hotel in thailand um and of
course they want to make it seem like
you know they they have service people
everywhere so of course you know in in
some hotels they have people in the
toilet to hand out towels
right to hand out towels and you know
just you know freshen up if you if you
need to freshen up so i'm going this way
there and the guy asked me if i want to
tell and i said no no it's okay so i go
up and go to the urinal and i hear some
footsteps i was like what's going on is
there someone else about um and then i
feel two hands on my shoulder
as i'm missing
and i'm just like and it's just like the
most awkward piss i've had in my life oh
my god i'm like i'm like it's at this
point it's just like it's just it's like
i'm like struggling to get it out now
because i'm going i have someone named
my shoulders because i'm like trying to
piss in this urinal right and he must
have saw how stiff you
say oh you're a bit stiff there buddy
all right and so we finished and i go up
to uh i go up to the sink to wash my
hands and uh i look at him and he's
expecting a tip from oh no i'm just like
huh which one
i think you already gave him
it's probably the most awkward tip i've
given in my life because i'm just like i
really don't want to give you this tip i
can just imagine you just like slowly
turning around it's just like the jojo
like behind the shoulder
that's awful that's that must be on the
top 10 list of places you don't want to
be messing yeah pushing in a urinal
that's got to be up there
abandoned chips i already know like when
people talk to me when i'm standing in
front of you right let alone getting
massage
christ wow any other any other places
you've been massaged
i think that's that's it yeah
let's never speak of massages again
by the way congrats on getting verified
by the way i don't know i don't think
you were verified last time uh that's
that's like beyond getting a studio
beyond k martin
[Music]
you're supposed to be like are you an
influencer yes blah blah blah japan
i was like film director yeah
i was like are you going to tarantino
yeah and like i've been doing it wrong
and i did it right there one time it was
like done in like one minute
i got a bit too
that's on the same level
but you know i've been doing it wrong so
yeah i was glad i was happy
what's the highlight of your year chris
oh [ __ ] i don't know
there's lots of cool things um
yeah what's the oh too much volcano yeah
oh yeah we talked about that top 14 19
is here probably that and then why did
you say top 14 just say it was 14th top
14 top 14. you know what just say top
50. how much it make it made like it
made a whopping how much do you think it
made
top fourteen twenty thousand dollars
um
how much do you think i'll tell you tell
how much money yeah i ironed out fifteen
thousand dollars
it made two thousand dollars
we split it three ways let's go
to build your new studio that is it
that's the money went towards that he
said he would split it but we never
sought the money
i gave you a trip to hokkaido
he invited me to the studios like he's
he's
too much volcano money right now thank
you
i mean yeah it's been a good year like
the studio is good and yeah because
everything right they're supposed to get
the kimono documentary out
in december but
it's just really hard to edit it i i'm
really like embarrassed watching it back
because i
i completely crumbled as an interviewer
i was going to try and speak japanese to
him yeah and then my mind just went when
i'm because it's just weird you're
sitting here there's ken white here he's
got a coffee i've got a coffee i'm like
so then ken oh god and also i didn't
sleep the night the night before i met
him i didn't sleep at all
nervous yeah i was [ __ ] there yeah
i was nervous as hell and i didn't sleep
at all and so i was like uh ken um
that's rubbish
my performance i wasn't happy with it
you said you were starstruck
it was a little bit but not he's quite
not just a normal guy he was in last
samurai
[Music]
and also like the best actor in japan
but like a normal guy
but
it was just weird it's just so trippy i
was just sitting there with k martial it
was really weird
i just like how you just call him a
normal guy in life he's a normal guy
he's he's that other normal guy
oscar-nominated japanese actor that tom
guy's a pretty normal guy as well
but he is nice blake
i mean i don't blame you i think anyone
would be [ __ ] thinking he spoiled
inception for me though told me to tell
me about this he was like
yeah i've seen it you know there's a
spinner that keeps on going oh yeah for
interpretation the endings he's like
he's like he's like oh it just keeps on
spinning oh like he's he's in the dream
world i was like i was like you've just
ruined inception for me oh no he's he's
in the real world mike michael kane
actually ruined it i think
because i believe
that
he's in the i was kenzie was in the fake
world and he was like he was in the
script but it was what's real it was
like in the script or something i i
think they actually
i think i actually broke her down for
like to like i think leonardo dicaprio
wears a ring or something in the real
world or like that's how you distinguish
between dream world and the real world
it's i think he wears a ring or there's
a piece of item on him that makes it
distinguish between real world and dream
world and in the last scene
he is in the real world would it be
would it be a large stretch to say that
both michael caine and ken watson harvey
may possibly be speculating it's
possible but i mean
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah maybe maybe they're like
planes
i'll say it's real
much that is compelling i think if he
said it's in the script that said that
i'm pretty i i don't think it was in the
script i think nolan told them
individually so maybe they just told
them different things
yeah maybe yeah it was like it's real
in the documentary i did at the end i
want to be like i had this scene where
i'm like ken i want to have like a
spinner and pretend like i don't have
him in the real world or not because i'm
interviewing kim watson or something and
apparently he's like yeah sure he was
really good at the spinner and he said
in inception every time they needed like
a spinner he would just come out and be
the one that did it because he was like
the best like spinning it little facts
about what's happening
he's great at spinning
spinning man
we've been in the last samurai spinning
normal spinning man in the last hour so
it makes him normal right
he can
i was intimidated until he got a spinner
out i started spinning it's like oh
thank god just a normal guy
[Laughter]
i guess because in in japanese culture
they have like the komar they do i think
you're very hospitable yourself as well
i'm pretty harsh on myself yeah yeah
yeah it's quite a serious documentary
yeah yeah it doesn't come out yet i need
to see it for myself if it's if it's
actually crumbly chris or if it's just
like
i'm to like use cgi to like make me look
good and be like the best
we need a question
hello there ken how are you doing and i
have like some weird synthesized version
of it
i'm still editing it and uh to make me
look good and not [ __ ]
because
we normally do an editing yeah yeah you
filmed that like a couple of months ago
right filmed in like october and
november yeah i met him twice yeah how
long is it going to be
25 minutes maybe
and it might be out by the time this
episode is out maybe
yeah um
maybe maybe it's going to get very yeah
maybe
it was good i went for dinner with him
and you know lots of people and like
this man this restaurant just came up to
him and ken the whole premise
documentary is he's like worked to help
sort of recover this town called
kesanuma destroyed by the tsunami and
then he's got a cafe there and he's done
a lot of great stuff for it but like
we're just out for dinner and like this
man just comes up and he's like oh ken
smile
thank
he's like thank you for the trumpets
like it turned out ken had to really
generously like donate like a thousand
trumpets to the town
that's probably more kids than in the
town there's nothing it might be why why
trump because he plays the trumpet he's
like get everyone on a trumpet so just
like it's just conversation i like trump
and he's like you've misremembered this
no he's like ken thank you do yourself a
trumpet thank you everyone
why because i like trump thank you for
the trumpet thank you for the trumpets
ken who's that what about the trumpets
oh yeah
what are you gonna do for the people of
wales
i just have this like i'm all aggressive
i just have this image of ken watanabe
going to this village which has been
like decimated by the tsunami and it
just goes you know what you need here's
a thousand trumpets you need a trumpet
to help the restoration efforts you know
but he's done an incredible job there
and i think that's really nice like he's
you know a lot of celebrities they get
involved just for the sake of it for pr
but he's actually befriended everyone
there and it's god really and the last
samurai top spinner trumpet dealer what
isn't it when are you donating yeah we
don't have a thousand shitty cosplays to
uh what would you do your village
the people of angels
in front of chris i'll pay someone to
come up and do it
when i'm
what do you donate chris what i don't
know yeah
very much
[Laughter]
this episode is sponsored by boxer do
you know what time of year it is uh it's
time for some loving job valentine's day
is upon us and do you know what will
please your beloved partner this
valentine my undivided attention and
maybe a box of chocolates no i'm so
offended that you would even insist that
it's not boxu because it is boxing
boxing makes such a perfect and
memorable gift for anyone in your life
who appreciates japanese snacks and
culture especially during a time where
people aren't able to travel as easily
as they would like because this season
we've got a couple of sweet and
delicious treats for you to try out make
your beloved ones as happy as a plum
this valentine's day with these homemade
umi sake candies this candy is flavored
with plum sake for an elegant sweet
treat next we have the tsuki samu and
pan chocolate here's a fun fact
gentlemen and pan is a sweet roll that's
filled with bean paste this ant pan gets
an upgrade with the addition of rich
chocolate
and lastly we have these hokugo purple
yams this purplicious pastry is called
manju and the bun is made with pie crust
and the filling gets an extra dose of
flavor and color from these mildly sweet
purple yeah what are you talking about
get all these lovely treats with bok su
and use our code trash taste 10 and the
link in the description to get 10
off your subscription what are you
waiting for get yourself and your
special loved one our boxing box this
valentine's day back to the show while
joey was away for a piss uh chris
revealed that he also doesn't know the
difference between a trumpet or trombone
i mean i know i just can't remember if
it was a trumpet or trombone because ken
could have donated
trombones to the village and uh chris
can't actually remember you have to
watch the documentary out abroad in
japan to find the
mystery will be sold how do you not know
the difference i can't remember what it
was the long one is the trombone yeah we
all know that
ghand doesn't know that because we all
know that
trombone trump yeah we all know the
differences
just say you're laughable
did you get a free subscription to the
japan times with your article uh like
how are you gonna read it
that's the problem in it i can't you
can't read the article you have to just
sign up because it's free i tried i
tried reading it i was like i'm not
signing up
don't worry reading it don't you read my
article i want to hear about this
so-called affable men i've yet to meet
the affable chris mused as he as he
leaned back on his ramen shop
oh my [ __ ] god but uh it's been a
good year yeah yeah what i want to know
is uh why do you feel like you had to
one-up our studio and uh build your own
chris yeah i mean i always i did i'll
admit when i came here i was like i want
a space now i've always wanted a space
this is what made you do it yeah i've
got one of those bastards
there might be three of them in the team
of 48 people well i'm going to one-up
them
by myself in a room with a massively
expensive set brilliant i think i think
you did one i'll possibly definitely did
pewdiepie call me a son of a [ __ ]
because he was jealous
someone sent me a clip and pewdiepie is
like [ __ ] lebron japan the
studio is great i was pretty happy about
that
i was pretty smug about that
no like
certainly when i came here i was like i
don't know why i haven't got a space yet
i've always put like unnecessary [ __ ] on
myself like not literally
shut up
i ain't sitting like across him because
his eye lines always [ __ ] there but
like he's always finding a weak spot i i
edited all the japan videos by myself on
a macbook up until last year i didn't
use a desktop with a screen that sounds
i literally talked to myself during the
broadcast why would you do that do you
even have two screens
no it's the macbook so i only got an
imac like last year in a proper screen
to edit on and it's sort of 10 years
almost 10 years in now it makes sense to
have a space yeah and honestly the most
i've used it for is just having meetings
with people and people come over it's
better than just like oh come on over to
my apartment watch out for the sock
drawer and the used family mart rappers
like
watch out
like it's nice to have a space where i
can actually sit and just create and do
things i guess to be fair though like
eighty percent of your content is also
outside as well but that was because i
had no space to film it right in japan
was born just me in an apartment
complaining about how much i hate what
we had we had the uh 12 days of
christmas christmas
please snickering at my clever title
so clever really clever really clever
that came up that there was the word
chris in christmas christmas genius
i finally figured it out only i could
have thought that but uh yeah it's just
cool david space to create and have
somewhere like that that ramen shop
that's just sort of been in my
imagination for years to have that sort
of
imaginary things imaginary set
translated to real life it's kind of
crazy thing and i've had some actual
serious film companies message me about
doing something in there oh so like i'm
from like hollywood like we want to film
some stuff in there wow sure okay um so
it'll be interesting to see what happens
going forward how long does that take to
make like what was the entire process
around that so the guy came in and i was
like i want a ramen shop there and a
street there and he probably went uh he
got a tape measure pulled out an ipad
just went
one just like this i was like that's it
but the man knew what he was doing was
really good
it was a company called giuli i think
and they they built like sets for alice
in borderlands and it looked like
netflix how did you find them just
through a friend he knew them you worked
with them and um and then they went away
they did a design they sent me like the
cgi what they look like and i was like
do that yeah that go
and uh and then they built it took about
three weeks to build it in a warehouse
in chiba where they built disneyland
rides right oh wow there's something
like footage of like men crafting lights
and woodwork and neon lights and [ __ ]
wow this is pretty intense and then took
three days to build it in the studio and
i wasn't there that time i think i was
on wacky weekend with you or something
when i was doing it and i came back to
sendai and i met the team and they were
all just like dead they like they hated
me they were like because they built
sets like film and tv yeah and my like
my studio is like in a decrepit building
from the 60s it's like filled with
asbestos it's coming there's cracks over
the wall the building's coming down yeah
and like they're like shifting like this
equipment through like an elevator and
stuff and they look dead and i was like
well done everyone they were like
get me out of it
but uh yeah it wasn't cheap
obviously but it's kind of like a i mean
a lot of people sort of ask me how much
it costs how much does it cost but like
i don't want to say because like
everyone will that will be like the
thing everyone thinks of right yeah yeah
consumed by that and yeah yeah it's
expensive but it's i could have spent
i'll say it was in the tens of thousands
uh yeah oh yeah
yeah of course
literally the like amount of electronics
in that place yeah the electronics alone
were almost half the cost i think the
most expensive thing was the crafting
the woodwork and everything oh yeah they
got the counter built which i remember i
saw the space before you had it in there
i thought you were telling me there's
going to be this set here i was like no
you can't play that's why he was so like
can't shocked when he saw it right i was
like yeah i was like i was like you're
taking the piss you know can't fit a set
in here it's like a [ __ ] bedroom like
yeah yeah you can't put anything in
there they're doing a great job with the
space they really like it's insane how
much they utilize they knew exactly what
they were doing and so much yeah it's
like an investment in myself for a broad
japan and um yeah because you've been
doing more content on your second
channel yeah yeah
christmas yeah
christmas it's definitely worth it
i remember when you i remember when you
told me about that early on you're like
i'm going to upload daily for 12 days
good luck i've always got there i've
always got there
how was it doing the consistent content
back-to-back they remind me
it reminded me why i don't do
consistency
you don't have time to think do you you
don't i i got a comment that really
annoyed me uh i don't get triggered that
often
because i've been putting all these like
12 days of christmas on my second
channel yeah yeah yeah hello everyone's
got a second channel now it's cool
and uh
the race is on he's gonna have the
biggest second channel but like
someone's like he's just rehashing old
videos because we did i think i did a
video with you we just talked about
things that we don't like about japan
and we have overrated things yeah and i
did meet with ryotaro about how we
nearly died and you know just sitting
down in the chat and i was like come on
mate
just casual spend the entire [ __ ]
year on horseback or on a plane or a
train on a ferry like doing these videos
can i just sit in a room and talk about
something for five minutes like let me
just chill let me just sit in a room so
that's like the second channel yeah
that's the whole point of the second
channel we have like second channel
exactly technically our third channel
because i guess trash chase is our
second channel yeah it's like a really
cute tweet that was from a verified
account and i was tagged in it for some
reason and they were like chris for some
reason i i can't seem to find these
videos on your channel
and they didn't realize that he had a
second channel on oh that's so cute
i don't know why i wasn't right and then
i closed twitter
she told them nothing that's the only
wholesome thing i've ever read on
twitter that's awesome i was like i just
thought that christchurch won one place
but it's nice of a second channel as i'm
sure you guys have found it's nice to
just chill out because the pressure you
can put yourself on with the first
channel yeah yeah
sometimes you just have an idea for
content that you're like i can't put
this on my first channel sure yeah
exactly this is wait
no that's main channel content like joey
going through is a health card school
yeah i went through my health card
school on my second channel what are you
doing then
bro
it would be like yes so everything's
great arch cholesterol's dreadful that's
basically what i said
yeah i mean i i i go to basically like
a's and b's and everything and then
urine came up and i got a c three and i
was just like how do i how do i [ __ ] up
in europe how do i how do i control my
obviously
i'm not being massage enough while i'm
urinating because something's going
wrong with that process
bad blood last year has it gone up to a
now it's it's uh it's a b now oh okay
wrong with your urine
i have no idea it's like acidic i guess
drinking too much wine
too much green tea
what was your results chris
i haven't done a test
let's get your
[Music]
the first three years they do it every
year right yeah yeah my after my second
year it was like really bad because i'd
smoked a lot and i drank a lot of the
time
the doctor like fell off his seat when
he saw
made your cholesterol look healthy
he was like whoa i fell off the chair
like humpty [ __ ] dumpty
it was awful
and i had to spend the next year just
like eating a leaf and chicken
oatmeal and despair
[Laughter]
no no my cholesterol now must be
horrific
i'm worried about it why am i laughing
laughing at my imminent demise i
understand because i have a similar
situation you're gonna get tested then
or you're just gonna put that off
i don't really know
i don't have a big company backing me
i'll just walk in like put something in
my arm go do it
i think you're just going to like yeah
if you just bulk it you can get like a
full like like a standard health checkup
that's where you can make a content out
of that that's that's another second
channel that's a second channel video
right there that's a narrative content
did you do the thing we have to drink
barium and they like have it they're
really nice i think that's if you have
stomach issues or when you're older i
think they can't do that but i'll
probably do that then is it 40 you have
to get a colonoscopy
endoscopy yeah i was like i was worse
than the hotel room we stayed and that
was like the worst thing i've ever had
in the world were you awake for that
yeah oh god i went i went to like the
worst doctor ever and
i thought it would be like a little
thing
right yeah and there's a cable like that
thick oh
and he's like this will numb your throat
it didn't
and i was like
i like and they had like this doctors
was really bad it's so bad that it's
closed out i think it must
help
send eyes somewhere and like they were
like they did the endoscopy they did
like a broom cupboard no and i was next
to like the room where everyone's
waiting and i was like
just like gagging for about 25 minutes
over and over you sure you went to a
doctor
well might have just been like close to
its house closed down because i don't
think it passed the test but like just
some dude in the lab and then and worst
of all they they took them
they had a screen in front of me like a
42 inch plasma screen of like
and then they printed it out and they
pulled it out and it's just horrible you
have to work a mouthpiece and they feed
it through it
it's almost it's it's up there with tea
waterboarding uh but like it sounds like
a scene out of sauce yeah you know you
just did you just wake up you just got
the mouthpiece on that's honestly you
have to escape the indus copy
they were supposed to print out five
photos and after two photos they ran out
of paper
and the images were not stored anywhere
so they're lost
and right i saw the guy exasperated and
like the nurse they're like
oh and he looks at me like we we ran out
of pitch
that's how he's here yeah he's spoken
kind of right and like he sort of
insinuated that we should probably do it
again oh my god no no we're good we're
fine don't worry
no cancer we're good i'd like [ __ ] you
know
jesus what did you just check for what
really bad like stomach acids like three
why i discovered it basically i was
really stressed for a long period of
time i really bad like stomach acid
like a stomach ulcer
yeah i think this was off this was i
don't know when this was
uh i think stafford started going
youtube full-time
do youtube yeah it's great and i was
really stressed and burnt out and so on
my stomach was just acidic yeah yeah so
they did that and um
yeah [ __ ] it was one it was probably
like the top three worst experience ever
got a really bad curvature at one place
and i was like wait what are we doing it
they were like oh just come here follow
us
it looks like the [ __ ] emergency
stair stairway like outside the fire
escaped yeah you do the same thing oh
that place that you did in the fire
escape
and then he was like alright open your
mouth and i'm
like i was like why are we doing it
outside he's like oh because uh it's
ventilated the office isn't ventilated
because if you have covered we don't get
it and i'm like
i feel like there could have been a
better solution to this like
out in like overlooking like roppongi
just watching like everyone walk by
while i'm getting something shoved down
my throat god it's awful jesus as for
the place we went to before flying back
to england right yeah it's weird yeah
that experience is why i'm like i don't
think i need the doctor again
again
i've heard really good and just really
bad about japan never like oh yeah sorry
i think endoscopy is the worst thing you
could do in japan i'm sure you can top
it connor what have you done that's bad
the ear thing is pretty bad oh [ __ ]
what the ear cleaning stuff people do
for fun
it's horrible that is horrible because
you know i don't clean my ears
you don't no gross grateful no a lot
most doctors recommend not to put
anything in your ear oh really nothing
should ever be going in your ears
if you if you're watering it would come
out you'd call it a smack
you shouldn't put cotton buds in your
ear even on the package the cotton buds
say they say cotton balls are the worst
yeah the combines are the worst
do you do
itchy no i get my ears getting my eyes
get really cheap
so you know this guy goes in and starts
scraping the [ __ ] eardrums
yeah but people love it on youtube for
some reason people absolutely it's like
pimple popping videos yeah that's the
same genre i helped sharla film her
video because she she did it once i
think it made loads of views and she's
like everyone loves this i'm gonna do it
again yeah i want to film it i was like
yeah sure i went along and you get like
a live feed yeah it's awesome
always with live feeds
[ __ ] inch plasma screen tv and you
you're the optimal viewing angle that
you can't look away watching
stop him at one point and be like i
gotta go and i need to go and sit on the
toilet i was just like i was like lying
on this toilet bowl just like
was that from was that though from him
going into your ear or from the footage
both both so like just seeing
seeing the footage combined with like it
was really painful yeah
i don't ever touch my ears yeah i don't
think probably super sensitive so it's
super sensitive obviously people who
clean theirs all the time it's not a big
deal you know you can do it but i
haven't done it and this guy's going ham
on me
he's good at what he does
boss man knows how to do it don't get me
wrong but holy [ __ ] i was not ready and
then he was like no we're not done yet
we need to get a deep clean and he
starts going deeper and it really feels
like he's like really inside like i
would have never put anything even
closer scratching your eardrum really
far to a point where i was genuinely
concerned and you know some some doctors
are like yeah it's a load of [ __ ] this
whole ear cleaning stuff it doesn't do
anything and it's dangerous because you
can pop your trunks yeah yeah it was
yeah it was genuinely like i wouldn't do
it again
that was it wasn't my idea it was it was
cow
right i was like yeah whatever sure i
mean it sounds disgusting but they did
yeah did they find anything how much do
they clean oh like [ __ ] they find
anything okay
it's a society
after a flooded pass and the sewage
system has been cleaned out yes it was
like
it was like the red sea parting in my
ears it was finally seeing there but i
mean you know it was um it wasn't not
fun because i i actually bought one of
the those ear picker things with the
camera at the end of it yeah
you can you can get sydney born yeah
you can connect it on your phone to see
it yeah no i i remember i remember i
cleaned my ears pretty often
i remember one time a few a few years
ago actually now um so me and cindy went
swimming once in a pool right and so one
one time we went swimming and we went
out and she had some water stuck in her
ears and normally just
shake it out yeah yeah shake it out so
this water just would not get out of
here
so it would it was stuck in there and i
was just like just just lay like that
just like that it's fine it's fine yeah
um
and it just packed and so this water
just wouldn't come out i don't know
where this is going yeah so so he stayed
in there for like days to the point
where her ears started hurting because i
guess an affection
so you get like an ear infection so we
actually had to go to the doctor right
so we took her to the doctor
and the doctor tries cleaning her ears
and they can't like for some reason they
can't get this liquid out right so it's
really disgusting even hearing that yeah
so so what they had to do was they had
to they put this solution in right
there's some kind of solution which like
softens the ear wax yeah yeah yeah so
they put the solution in and left in for
like a good few minutes right i didn't
know what i was expecting uh because i
didn't know how i didn't know what was
blocking her ear canal this bad and so
they put this they put the uh put the
liquid in drain it and then they get
like this uh mini mini kind of vacuum
kind of thing just like vacuum out and
kind of clean the air right
now all right so i just remember i just
so i just remember right i just remember
sydney lying down and the nurse just
like vacuuming vacuuming vacuuming her
ear out right just waiting for something
to come out and then out plops this ball
of black earwax like you could hear the
splat on the ground like this this
wasn't ear wax this was like a [ __ ]
lovecraftian nightmare creature nothing
it was like the thing i swear to god
like i was not expecting that right not
even the nurse was because like this
this ball just drops out of her ear and
me and the nurse are just looking at
this ball like eyes wide open and
just like takes takes it and sydney's
like what what what what what and uh
she's like what's happened but like i'm
just like sydney you do not want to see
what just came out of your [ __ ] yeah
it was massive i didn't know that i
didn't know earwax to get that big
because i've had that before as well
because i have like really naturally
very tough earwax like it's like very
dry earwax top trunks in there yeah it's
like it's like naturally really really
dry the smelliest
mine's like naturally really dry so if i
don't clean it out consistently then it
hardens and turns into like rock form
and then that's when you get like the
whole water stuck in your ear yeah your
infection
i used to get hearing aids like if you
start doing it it just starts happening
and then sure i have to i used to get
ear infections all the time as a kid
because i had just like rock heart
infection in my life yeah i mean once
when a bumble bee went in my ear and
stung in my ear oh jesus
that triggered an ear infection yeah
oh this is horrible how was that oh well
i was like six running around in the
field having fun
that was the last time chris had fun
ever
i can't even do it yourself [ __ ] air
cleaning disgusting yeah yourself
colonoscopy
because it's like apparently it's like a
thing that japanese couples do they
clean each other's ears and stuff it's
you say colonoscopy
all right honey bend over
you laugh but there's probably a couple
or two out there
yeah no my mom used to clean my ears all
the time when i was little that's
probably why you're getting like ear
infections because she started the cycle
of cleaning
there though yeah you're not supposed to
put anything in there like it's i don't
know why but japan is obsessed with
being clean that's probably why i love
the trash taste podcast you learn about
the important things yeah hygiene top of
the list who needs anime anymore i just
play more anime it's just an infection
oh do you have an ear infection no i've
never had one yeah i used to get them
all the time it was horrible yeah
i mean i feel like the wax is like a
natural barrier of shorts no it is it is
conspiracy
the body is natural i mean it's it's
there for a reason right it's like dust
and [ __ ] getting in but there are some
times when
there is just a big buildup of wax and
it just gets like it really gets itchy
bidets
uh i mean yeah like doctors have them
maybe they're doing an ambitious same
one in the toilet
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you see that thing in the news
recently with the 5g necklace
they can get a necklace that's supposed
to like stop the waves of 5g hitting you
can't be seen it turns out this necklace
is radioactive
it's got [ __ ] plutonium in it and so
the sheer irony that people are trying
to you know get rid of the dangerous 5g
and they're wearing this necklace like
the hulk it's like carcinogenic and it's
like oh my god you're off your rockers
it's quite a quite a new story it's kind
of like the uh covered necklaces that
japan was selling oh yeah yeah
yeah so so apparently they were selling
these necklaces
yeah that like that gave everyone who
wore them like a protective shield yeah
yeah yeah on the packaging there's like
this happy woman and there's just like
this dome shaped like shield around her
like yes you're free of all the viruses
what's in it
i don't know plutonium
uranium 45.
something radioactive yeah
places where all the staff are wearing
them i'm assuming that the company's
like you have to wear these yeah
customers oh my god yeah no i mean i
[ __ ] i remember when i went back home to
um see my mum some of our family members
had sent them
the necklaces as well i was like mom you
know this is [ __ ] right you know
you know you can't have a necklace that
just that just prevents viruses that's
not how viruses work yeah the virus
rocks i was like oh [ __ ] he's got an
honor
[ __ ] harry potter spell or something
it's like virus be gone you
know more useful than the shield and
dune though at least
i can block anything that [ __ ] shield
and dune
oh well i mean to a degree
just [ __ ] was paper it didn't do
anything they just turned it on what
just to waste energy well no that's why
they didn't have guns in dune right yeah
that's that's the whole point that's the
whole law that's they still got shot and
[ __ ]
pretty sure someone got exploded
there's no gun
james bond no time to die it's time it's
time
it's time to die it's time yeah what do
you think about it
what was the point of him being the
worst villain ever really so [ __ ] you're
not seeing it you're not born man
gosh doesn't go to the cinemas in japan
you don't i mean i don't go to the
cinemas in general unless there's a film
i really really really want to see like
psycho pass
maybe
maybe you know if there is a psychopath
movie if akira was in cinemas i'd go see
a q oh [ __ ] yeah cause i haven't seen in
cinemas and i think that's it's one film
that you would appreciate way more on
the big screen yeah like doom yeah
why didn't you go watch it in cinemas i
don't understand i just i wasn't in
cinemas for like three months yeah yeah
i don't know i i actually would i
actually was just like oh is it in
cinemas like last week googled it wasn't
so i was like [ __ ] it i guess i'll just
watch it
sometimes i just get lazy you know
because for three months huh
[Laughter]
[Music]
anime that you weren't paid to watch
[Laughter]
yeah jojo
all right
arcane jojo
you know sometimes you just have
something that's not on the top of your
priority list and then it just slips and
then you miss your opportunity
unfortunately yeah i've said this a
billion times but i just like the
theater experience it's just a good the
right way to enjoy a movie well i mean
the matrix might have been a bit mere
but the you know in the cinema imax it's
the first time i've seen a matrix movie
in a cinema because it came out in 1999
i was nine yeah and uh so it was pretty
cool watching like a matrix movie the
way it was supposed to be sort of yeah
the imax was incredible
uh what are you a marvel guy at all
yeah i want to see the new spider-man i
absolutely love spider-man 2.
one of my favorites probably my favorite
which would spider-man
the original one the original one okay
alfred molina
yeah it's a cracker
i watched dark waters last week what's
that exactly where'd you find time to
watch all these films yeah don't just
get an evening you should go and i'll
stream afterwards or something
are you gonna watch spider-man uh well
when it comes out for some reason japan
it comes out like three weeks after the
rest of the world yeah so the matrix
came out here like before anywhere else
because there's like a seed in japan
maybe that's why but like every film in
japan comes out so late it's so nice
it's either it's too early or too late
yeah because it's too early
it's too early
by the time it comes out the spoiler
lift is going to be gone on like online
right yeah there's a two-week spoiler
period where no one's about to allow to
spoil it and by the time that's gone the
film still hasn't come out in japan so
i'm probably going to know what happens
in it before i even go see this i just
haven't read anything about
i know what it
give me your full inception what what
give me
ken did that don't worry give me you
give me fifty dollars i won't tell you
what how about you [ __ ] off
black movie blackmail spoiler blackman
spoiler black man yeah there's a lot of
i i watch a good amount of the western
releases in japan
i don't even like
look what it's about i just go up just
watch it
sometimes to
pour
rates of success i'd say this was a good
movie it's just mark ruffalo being like
for like two hours
it's pretty sounds amazing
what is the film about yeah
about how like dupont a chemical company
just poisoned everyone in the world
basically sick sounds like a writer and
and how like they did it for like four
years and mark ruffalo is like the
lawyer that finds out and like shoes
them and stuff so it's based off a true
story yeah it's like still ongoing as
well oh wow yeah
the film or the uh oh the real life
character yeah it's like poison like
everyone in the world oh wow what the
[ __ ] yeah
everyone's been poisoned by this one
chemical that they were dumping yeah
it's pretty sketchy though now it's like
one of the un's like priorities to like
ban this chemical it's pretty good movie
though
it's pretty good
really you're really selling ourselves
you're really [ __ ] paranoid to drink
any water
activated charcoal can't finish no it's
fine it's a good movie uh mark ruffalo
he's all right i think he's not like the
best actor on earth but he's just kind
of okay in every film he's pretty yeah
he's pretty good
like he's not like amazing i'm never
compelled by his performance yeah yeah
what have i seen him in that's not
marvel collateral tom cruise
yeah he plays like an underwhelming
detective he thinks
he's really good at playing like a wimpy
character yeah which i don't know
mark ruffalo's agent he's got a [ __ ]
role ready
he's not he's too cool that character
because he's kind of like a pushover in
the film but it kind of
plays to his uh strengths because then
he kind of gets over it and it develops
character character development yeah
well mark ruffalo he's watching this in
a room in l.a like [ __ ] hey he's [ __ ]
a billionaire he doesn't need my [ __ ]
billionaire doesn't need my [ __ ]
sympathy yeah because i notice when the
movie starts it's like a film by mark
ruffalo corp or something it's like it's
his movie company mark oh is it yeah so
it's his movie it's something they're
always saying funny about that i don't
know why just having an actor star in
their own film i'm always like well
we're going to get a conor colon movie
what
about what me [ __ ] doing a crane game
for two hours
uncut the the quest for curious george
yeah the director's cut
the [ __ ] would i make a film
i have no interest in making a film
though if i gave you a hundred million
dollars what would you make more crane
game
yeah someone must have done that
probably did you see those uh that one
hamster channel they got like a lot of
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it's squid
games
like making these hamsters drop from
like massive like gods and there's like
spikes and stuff jesus is awful
i i watched the video and it was like
it's honestly not that bad like i don't
know there was some bits where i was
like yeah that that hamster could have
been impaled
uh
what if what if the uh hamsters were
just cg'ed in yeah what if the support
of this
is
unfortunately i think there's one thing
that you cannot even remotely try and
get away with and that is anything with
you comes close to abusing animals yeah
it's like the one thing that you just
can't get away with i mean right so yeah
i think that's that hamster video was
just a bit
yikes yeah they're definitely better
ways to do what i feel yeah but it's a
bit it's a shame as well because that
channel like i i've been because that
[ __ ] channel comes up my recommended
all the time because he like makes
little miniature like onsens and like
massage parlors and like little sets for
his hamsters like kind of play around
yeah there's like a little mini
waterboarding scene
yeah but it's like it's really cute and
it's like you know
and then for some reason he was just
like yeah i'm just gonna
make them fight to the death he would
make hamsters drop right from like here
onto the floor
it's not deadly but it's like why would
you make it it's not deadly but i'm sure
you know one bad fall and it could
i think it's a hamster i'm done with
squid game it was it's the right tv show
but let's never speak because we've done
it better christmas
octopus game is a squid game it's good
it's good yeah it's good what would you
change just got it you just don't want
to hear about it ever again
it's been done a lot right you know
we've it has been a lot of squid gaming
yeah that's that's never i think you
think i got too popular
i i think i i just
you know i i get a bit annoyed with
things that everyone obsesses over i
remember well i remember when i was here
when frozen came out right and yeah
you might have been there but like it
was like everyone got so obsessed with
every [ __ ] story
that song was like every day like 400
times oh i want to kill someone and i
felt like that about squid game a little
bit it was a good show it was good i
enjoyed it a lot but like when you just
hear about something you're bombarded by
something so much japan's so good at
that though it's like when there's like
one like viral like song that's high in
the charts like [ __ ] like you know
any song any it could be anything it's
just like every second store is [ __ ]
blasting it my favorite thing is when
japanese stores play obscenely
inappropriate songs in english
in like a children's day care because
they don't know what any of the words
mean
they're like rap that's like super like
[ __ ] yeah i i remember i went to this
toy story in shibuya once they were
playing lap
like loud on the speakers i was like ah
they were playing whap in one of the
supermarkets i go to as well
and i was like the uncensored version i
was like whoa i'm like there's like
there's like all these like disney toys
everywhere and i'm just like
kind of wholesome about it
a family restaurant they're playing 50
cents in the club
and i was like eating like a ham
sandwich or something just listening to
hitting the club
[Laughter]
[Music]
loudly
no no i'm not putting it on over there
it's a hoodie you can't wear it with a
raw skin
skin
raw skin
exposed skin my next youtube channel
those
[Music]
which one was the most expensive
probably the yuckier one
that
where's where's the other akira in the
other room oh okay oh
how do you put on a hoodie like a boomer
i don't know how you've managed to find
a way to do it
do you put it on there it's a [ __ ]
hoodie
oh my god chris in a hoodie just looks
like that [ __ ] like hello fellow kids
we need to give you a skateboard now oh
my god am i one of the kids now you
should have worn the cap that you wore
in the
previous episode
that's premium material that chris
that's an embroidery right there 88
it's good material right
that's good
that's right
it's just so weird
or something right yeah
this is a size too big yeah it's a large
around the bushes
[Laughter]
so what are your goals for 2022 what's
what we're going to expect from trash
here we can see a special
pewdiepie and mr b stone
uh people from outside japan as much as
we want you on for like a fifth time
cruise
when the good when the japan finally
opens up
again
i'll be like
i don't even know how to get here like i
got on a taxi i was late i got a taxi
right yeah and i put the address in for
this studio it just does not compute on
google for every reason
so i i put in the dress for somewhere
nearby like it was a domino's pizza
such a [ __ ] going from tokyo station
to a dominoes and like take me to the
dominos
i was like
what about the fighting one
scrapped kendo
[Music]
this is the man who has traveled all of
japan
[Laughter]
right that's nothing is there some yes
so i my friend
who who can get me like anyone to
interview he's like who do you want to
be on i don't know
anyone i know i know i go you can
probably like get me anyone bring me
anyone
and i just don't have any idea i don't
really i don't really like i don't
there's no one i actually want to
interview prince andrew
he's amazing
much worse than the last [ __ ]
interview
expression welcome
bet you are like
i love that interview
i don't know and the problem is i the
comment i get a lot is like
production quality so good production
quality i don't really production
qualities i don't really care about that
it's important have a standard yeah yeah
yeah
but or not if it's a gerry vlogger i
think you've just got the second channel
video i think you've just done it so
much that you i think you just
subconsciously put it together really
well yeah i don't think you're like this
this mastermind that everyone thinks you
literally just turn up but you make the
most of every situation i think i think
you're pretty good at filming on the
spot maybe yeah just have a knife
whereas whereas i would give after after
two takes and be like [ __ ] it chris is
like we'll just piss everyone off and
make us do like four more takes because
chris is not happy with it like the
stanley cup
this whole direction
we're all freezing dying hungry
i need this drone shot the colonoscopy
will go on
you could be in my film
what's the film something very bad
chris
i'm predicting that's right christopher
i want to be my movie what'll it be so
be the racist white man or something
that's what he would do no acting
required
you should do his best to make me just
basically lean out of the caprio from
django
where's the script it's like
[Laughter]
your character is gluttonous you have to
eat this entire wank sober it's like oh
my god
i don't know honestly i don't know what
to do this year though i would like to
do something outside japan a little bit
yeah
get out there well i haven't listened in
like 10 years
i haven't left japan in two years plus
now and uh
japan is a country you need to get out
of at least once a year
uh because it's like one big one big
[ __ ] library and you have to sort of
be very careful with your manners and
you've got to be you know switched on
all times thinking about how you're
affecting other people yeah it wears you
down and uh yeah you do need to get out
once a year
pretty tough not not going back or doing
anything i left the shores of japan for
two years now when was the last time you
like filmed a video in like outside of
japan like in the uk or wherever i think
i've only done it like once wasn't
asking the movie
oh and that yeah that was it yeah that
was it let's see the movie and one other
movie right yeah yeah or one other video
another yeah but yeah i just need to get
out for a bit i was yeah i was planning
to go back for christmas like uh you
guys were and
any way you want to film aside from
krakatoa
i do want to see that
can we climb krakatoa is that i think i
thought i think to a certain point
i'll direct i'll be doing the drone
you can climb i'll be doing the driving
i'll do the drive i'll do the drone
but i do want to do taking for granted
and i i know a place we could bungee
jump in my
yeah that sounds fun
[ __ ] hell i would like
i'm not [ __ ] doing it yeah yeah i'll
do it all right we'll film that or strap
some gopro
i wouldn't mind skydiving honestly but i
think bungee jumping i would not want to
do
there's something like like there's
something scary about an awkward height
you know what i mean like where's like
because like for me sky diving is like
you're so high up where height doesn't
matter anymore
i've heard so many funny stories about
bandage jumping in like really sketchy
countries yeah yeah
people do die doing it yeah i read an
article last year gail did it and the
rope just wasn't [ __ ] tight exactly
let's be honest the one country you
probably want to bungee jump in with
confidence is probably japan yeah yeah
the man the man is like i made this rope
by hand it's all handcrafted or
something passed down from generations
yeah it would be it would be like the
most immaculate bungee jump cordon
existence yeah needs to study it or
something yeah i bet it's amazing yeah
that's because that's how everything is
in japan yeah nothing can be subpar
to be like the best thing on earth
exactly that's the video chris there you
go what's the health and safety
regulations in japan
uh immaculate because okay okay here's
over the top here's the thing it's like
it's either one or the other because
sometimes it's like [ __ ] immaculate
you are not going to go to this place
unless everyone's signed off on it and
then you have like drifting where you
can turn up without a [ __ ] driver's
license yeah and go on the course i'm
just like so where does the line start i
feel like rules are made when people do
dumb [ __ ] and accidents happen yeah so i
feel like in some sense japan doesn't
have as many rules because they're just
so conscious about yeah stuff like that
yeah like i think like
everyone is just extremely clean here so
i imagine that their health rules
probably aren't as strict on like
i imagine maybe i think maybe they're so
clean yeah i think they're like in japan
because japanese people just like love
to follow the rules and are really good
at following the role so it's like just
have like a baseline rule set and then
most places will be like you're not
gonna do anything like weird and stupid
to like you know try and test those
limits right because everyone's gonna
follow the rules the drifting was fun
though yeah whereas with drifting they
were like do you have a license no all
right you can still go yeah all right
i'm glad i didn't drift that down i know
i'd have been sick like you were like i
want to see you when i was in the back
of it just for that like few minutes
it's way different when you're driving
it i think yeah like when you're in the
back you get way sicker yeah yeah it was
really fun i really want to do it again
yeah i want to that was fun yeah
i like to see i like to see you with
like the drift king drifting you around
hasn't flashed before my eyes before but
they definitely did during that uh
during that year
that drifting episode that was insane
yeah i don't know i don't even know one
on there i learned how to do that [ __ ]
i repeat this episode is sponsored by
manscape cheers to 2022 and resolutions
you can actually keep how about having
clean and shiny balls all year round our
sponsor at manscaped are here to save
your balls this year and make the ball
drop into 2022 the cleanest and sexiest
ever set your first new year's
resolution with good intentions and join
the four million men worldwide who trust
manscaped with our exclusive offer go to
manscape.com and use code trashtaste for
2010 off plus free shipping it's new
year new me with the global leaders in
below waste grooming this year take your
package to the next level with the
performance package 4.0 and brand new
ultra premium body wash
inside the performance packs 4.0 you'll
find the signature lawnmower 4.0 this
electric trimmer is designed to trim
hair on loose skin the advanced skin
safe technology reduces cuts and nicks
on your delicate nuts it also comes
equipped with a 4000k led spotlight that
will shine a light to the promised land
2022 looks to be so what are you waiting
for get 20 off and free shipping by
using code trash taste at manskip.com
that's 20 off plus free shipping at
manskip.com using code trash taste it's
a new year no pubes in 2020 two with
manscaped thank you for sponsoring these
nuts
speaking of wanker-shaped chris i know
another youtube creator you're very fond
of
nicaragua avocado right nick avocado
the guy that eats everything yeah and
cries yeah
what's the story behind him i mean i i'm
i'm not as good as you are like you're
like switched on i don't really know
i watched a four-hour video about him
that explained all his history and i
can't tell you anything about it oh the
right opinion video yeah it was
basically a guy just uh was getting
views doing mukbangs got fat and then
kind of just uh but he used to be like a
health conscious like vegan yeah he used
to be super thin
super healthy used to promote like
healthy eating an interesting character
yeah and then he did one mukbang saw how
big it got and then just oh that's sad
yeah
that's really sad yeah yeah and it's
it's i think it's going to the point now
where he is definitely playing a
character yeah he's playing it up he's
completely like but he's also very he's
also eating the food but he's also
killing himself it's uh it's method
acting
to the nth degree
i feel about eating fried chicken yeah i
remember when daniel day lewis was uh
eating all the fried chicken at the end
of the character
oh yeah that's sad though isn't it yeah
which mukbangs in general were like the
saddest thing on earth maybe i'll do it
what are you gonna do we basically did
that
what you did already right there
ramen as well something about avocado
man i feel like one off you're like all
right
what's his
don't get cholesterol like him sort it
out i think
i might i don't want to you know assume
but i think you might have higher
cholesterol than me oh really what but
sir he was health conscious when he just
got rid of it he just was like no
because they didn't get views he didn't
get views yeah so money was more
important money and drama got yeah he
basically chased the money and drama
like training
so yeah him eating unhealthy and drama
got him more views which in turn got him
more money so it was like a endless
spiral yeah it's a spiral i mean this is
this is the feature of youtube though
isn't it no just punishing yourself for
views i mean i've done that plenty of
times i think like a mukbang every now
and then is like all right whatever
you're not sure put your health at risk
but when you're like here's my my my
daily mukbang yeah 1500 chicken nuggets
it's just like maybe this is a sniper if
you're doing like a matte stoney where
it's like you know eat a gargantuan
amount of food once a month but also
work out vigorously
that's fine so that's what he does right
that's steady well i think he i think a
lot of the professional leaders they
they eat that large amount of food and
then the days off they pretty much just
don't eat much that yeah very very like
precise diet there's a there's a science
there's an essence yeah yeah like it's
like if you eat seven thousand calories
you've got to figure out how you can get
that out of your diet yeah or you can
have the lack of calories yeah yeah i
think he messaged me once because he did
the monster ramen challenge in akihabara
he's actually quite good about it he's
like one of the like best in the world
an avocado man just [ __ ] every day
yeah bucket of [ __ ] calling
yeah it's just like inhuman but like
he's also like pro like
professionally i guess to the point of
where he knows what he's doing is he
trained professionally well i mean i
guess i mean he competes he's like the
[ __ ] the king at it like no one beats
yeah i think there's like two a few
other people who are pretty as good as
him like i mean he's got a lot of the
records i think most of the stuff he
knows what he's doing yeah i think the
reason why he
uh doesn't upload as frequently is not
just for health reasons but i think it's
also because he's like doing like
professional eating competitions like
wow right i mean i'm guessing it's still
not healthy what he's doing no you sent
me a video of him just eating like 100
slices of cheese oh that was so gross
that looks this i wanted to throw up
just watching that video once he's had
his first endoscopy he'll think very
carefully in that
food fighting strategy i'm sure that man
has like the best health care money can
buy just
thought that if chris was american
that's how he'd look like i mean
it's just me with better teeth and the
better jawline and just everything
better where's the family malt chicken
challenge
after a bucket of chicken i mean it's
just depressing isn't it i feel like
there's only so much you can do before
you're just like i'm i don't i don't
like this anymore i'm just hurting
myself
i'm just in pain did you not feel like
that after you did your cup noodle
challenge what are you doing for awful
that's why that's why i only do it like
once every [ __ ] month after like one
cup noodle i feel like i feel insulted
i'm eating it all am i i'm taking one
bite of it yeah but collectively you
probably ate about five or six cups yeah
six six old cards it's a brave map or
idiot a lot of sodium yeah too much
sodium iso too much sodium
well again it's one of those things like
you're not doing it often so whatever
really i mean cholesterol's still high
but you know are you gonna do more i
tried xyz videos i tried everything
there's just not that much to do it's
interesting you're kind of covered in
christians it's pretty rubbish it was
just like they look the same but it was
also because i just moved in and like
everything was a mess and we couldn't
get any of the camera set up or live
connor's apartment and like he had
no curtains yeah we had the curtains
to block out the sun he used
like
like 20 boxes and a blop doll or
something
his collection of dodgy
video tapes still he loves mother's nose
breasts
the masterpiece of our time he couldn't
stop giggling when he saw it he was like
what why is mother those breasts
suggested watch it or no
she should have what is mother knows
brush
[Laughter]
what's his favorite shirt wonderful he's
these tapes to block out like the sun
yeah he's like somewhat
porn eclipse like just block out the sun
below solar eclipse
it was yeah it did not work well and the
christmas was just they all were just so
[ __ ] there's nothing interesting about
if you've been the uk would have been
really good as much as
us
it just really showed how depressing
crisps orange yeah what did uh somebody
messaged me in the week and said chris
your friends with the trash taste lads i
was like oh yeah and
of course i am i don't know if you next
time you see him tell him to stop going
so hard on america what have you done i
think it was you as well it's like
particularly in collar what have you
said about america that's made everyone
happy
we've still said a lot of stuff we've
said a lot more than they've said about
the uk quite frankly
what's your opinion of america chris
that's right i don't i mean i don't it's
silly to make sweeping generalizations
about the entire country
it's not actually like generalizing the
entire population this is for jokes i
think in the uk
we're like a little bit snobby towards
americans of course we are
[ __ ]
calling every garage chicken everywhere
towards everyone let's be honest we
invented the rocket engine
we are a little bit envious because we
had an empire and then it was gone and
then america had had a bigger and better
economy
you know i think i do you know i think
like british people hate about americans
is that they look happy
that's true you know i i i
i think americans hate what they can't
and everyone's so optimistic and happy
and like patriotic and we're here just
being like country [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] why are they so
happy they're not allowed to be that
makes sense what we should learn from
americans is it's good to like have
dreams and be optimistic
because
we don't have that in the uk i remember
like you know i used to work in office i
want to start a business they were like
[ __ ] off and get me my tea little prick
okay i like just having a dream in the
uk you just can't do that you're not
allowed
shut up and make the tea
sit down icarus give me my [ __ ] tea
like it's horrible the uk is horrible
could that possibly be a generalization
as well
imagining chris being scolded is the
funniest [ __ ] thing
just british people miserable in it we
are miserable i remember elon musk came
to the castle where i worked right my
boss was really
up tight [ __ ] of a woman and she's like
really [ __ ]
really like she's very posh like when
you work in a prestigious place you get
like really posh people then i look down
she was like there's billionaires coming
he's going to elon musk or something
started a company's worth 300 million
dollars
rubbish and i was like yes he's made a
company called tesla in spacex
he's gonna he's pretty big deal like she
was like really i looked down uh he
really looked down
i'm just
being american
nothing i was like
american american this woman
this this person i work with i just
just hated him because he was like
american and he came with like lots of
um
silicon valley investors and
all right powerful new picture idea to
them
that must be like the cringiest thing
you could possibly do
[Music]
let me deal with him and i'd like give
him the birthday cake because she didn't
want to she's got his fifty years
why today maybe she owned a tesla car
that was [ __ ]
i don't want to hear about him it was
very odd yeah but i you know we were
talking to god before we came on about
how like
if you go to a nice restaurant in japan
you just you don't feel judged it's nice
you go to a nice restaurant the uk like
a michelin star
you will feel like nothing you'll feel
like you're sure you feel out of place
there the class structure in the uk is
pretty
powerful still and uh you know if you go
in a nice restaurant you often know oh
what are you doing here especially when
you turn up dressed like me you're like
oh gosh what are you doing here
yeah the toilets are not here so like
it's just i don't really care where
you're from in japan but i feel like it
does matter a bit in the uk they're like
where'd you where did you grow up and
it's like it's just it's just
fascinating coming from a country that
doesn't have that like what what like
how does like where does it start how do
you distinguish between who is in the
same classes
1 000 years of history and money
because there's like so much old money
there right it gets inherited down and
they get uh brought up it just sounds
like your own [ __ ] circle in her and
[ __ ] environment it sounds like
racism within the same race i mean it's
called classism right yeah there's a
little name for it yeah
you said somebody made fun of you for
your clothes you're wearing yeah so i
went to this uh fancy restaurant in the
uk and uh someone laughed at us for
wearing you know wearing like uniqlo and
h m clothes disgusting disgusting
huh which what person was this like a
waiter or no just just someone sitting
at a table we got we got looks for you
know having having like
smart business casual clothes yeah
obviously none of it was like name
brands if i turn up in my primark jacket
i was always of the mindset the real
rich people like actual rich didn't feel
the need to dress smart they just turned
up in like [ __ ] pajamas
that's like american rich right where
people have new money in the uk yeah
there's old money right
passed down
yeah it's like name value to the money i
feel really at my depth in london when i
when i go back
to this place like that's why i bought
anything on one of the menu at
mcdonald's that's the real wealth that's
the flex power that's the real flex
right you guys want some nuggets so i
suppose i didn't buy another twenty
twenty pieces
oh
it's like london five-star hotels are a
joke
like it's like it looks like my
grandma's bedroom
like it's it's old and quaint and it's
been around for hundreds of years and
it's like yeah that's why my grandma
still has the [ __ ] bed it's [ __ ]
it's like this [ __ ] awful like you
know you see these rooms they have like
uh a
12 inch screen from like the 1980s they
have these bed sheets that look like
they're just decrepid yeah this oak
cabinet that looks like it's been around
longer than like the entirety of london
it's like it's [ __ ] and you pay like 400
pounds a night yeah you get nothing i
mean i feel japan kind of has that as
well with some of the dyokans as well i
i thought that until i stayed in some of
the london hotels and then i'd forgotten
how
how overpriced the service issue uh the
service industry is in the uk because
for for what you get in like the price
you pay for like you can you can stay in
some like
five-star hotels or whatever and you're
paying like four or five times the price
you would in japan and it would be like
half the size of the room with no
service it doesn't even come with
toothbrushes like like it doesn't even
come with toothbrushes which i i think
is like the bare minimum i remember that
yeah because in japan any even the worst
hotel in the world
we got a cheese we got two strawberries
i wouldn't use paint in like
molds and every day
but at least it came with a toothbrush
exactly right i think the uk doesn't do
it for like environmental waste yeah
yeah
which also just suddenly lines up very
nicely for these hotels because they
don't have to buy toothbrushes
yeah where where are the five stars
coming from in that case just just from
the name i don't understand how they get
five stars sometimes because i i think
it must be location half the time right
a lot of these five star hotels are in
amazing locations yeah the hotels are
dreadful
really bad don't go in a five-star hotel
in london just go to like a [ __ ]
premiere in or some [ __ ]
yeah airbnb maybe airbnb is like way
better yeah you get way better
than airbnb yeah
in england in general like pretty much
every hotel i've stayed in england
is like not the greatest i'll tell you
the time i got locked inside an airbnb
in england
i used to use airbnb a lot and then i
stayed in bath once for a holiday really
nice town called bath and uh it was in
like an attic
the door went open from the inside so as
i woke up that morning i'm gonna go for
a jog around bath and uh
you went to the door it just it just
wouldn't open i was like what the [ __ ]
and like there was no way i could open
it i rang up the guy i was like hey man
i can't get up the apartment this is
kind of weird this hasn't ever happened
in the history of ever and it happens
sometimes um
you short run open i was like no i was
like can you come and sort it out i was
like well i'm in bristol at the moment
which is about an hour away i was like
there's a fire i'm [ __ ] and like and i
had to wait like an hour for someone to
come and like open the door and let me
out of the apartment i was locked inside
and that put me off the airbnb in the uk
yeah the one did you uh leave a bad
review i think i did i was like got
locked in the room
that's who starts not as bad as it gets
yeah that is pretty bad
that's the only thing that i sometimes
don't like about airbnb is that there is
some weird unpredictable
natures
i did it in asakusa once and uh the
owner was like just just say you're our
friends
to say or you know just say you're
friends with takeshi
if you're lugging around like expensive
equipment i wouldn't i wouldn't go an
airbnb right yeah just don't trust it
like if i have my top camera stuff like
that yeah you have no insurance you have
no safety you know and
if it's if someone else also has the
keys it's a bit worrying yeah obviously
the hotel has
uh you know people say as well yeah you
can at least there's some level of
safety there and
there's cameras everywhere yeah it's
also cameras so it's you know it's it
depends if i was just traveling with me
somewhere on my own didn't bring my
laptop around and give a [ __ ]
and i tried to
last week when we were trying to make a
video we went to this really expensive
hotel room at 12 000 hotel room and i
wanted to contrast that with something
bad like a bad hotel room or a cheap
airbnb i'm trying to book three separate
airbnbs in tokyo and they're all like oh
it's open these few days and i booked it
and three times in a row i got rejected
uh they were like no we're full of day
and i got really angry at this point
about that i don't know if it's because
i you know i'm not japanese
a lot of people said afterwards that
they always book under a japanese name
i was quite disappointed about that i
was like oh maybe it's because of the
new omni variant and so they're being a
bit wary because i'm foreign but it's
still [ __ ] up though
classic japanese xenophobia over there
um there's been some nasty instances of
that since since covered
you know certainly yeah i've times i
felt like a second-class citizen in
japan because
you know before i would never have
accused japan of uh you know that that
level of uh discrimination but yeah
covert has really kind of brought a
weird side of japan it's a bit
uncomfortable a lot of people are
supposed to sort of
tainted their long-term future here yeah
a really good article about how like all
these travel restrictions have really
like tainted how a lot of people view
japan unfortunately they've just kind of
just completely
[ __ ] over foreigners who had jobs
residents yeah like really [ __ ] students
absolutely [ __ ] over a ton of people
and now they just put them back and said
they're gonna keep them going again
right after they release them it's
really [ __ ] it is bad yeah well i
remember like you got so bad that the
american embassy even made a tweet right
didn't it yeah yeah yeah jesus was the
tweet it was sent like we've been
informed that japanese police are
randomly stopping foreigners and
searching them oh yeah i had that the
other day yeah
the day after the tweet i was at the
nearby like uh
train station yeah and i was about to go
into the [ __ ] train thing and then a
cop just like stopped me oh sweet
it was like oh nihongo daijoubu and i'm
i'll give this cop credit he was nice
about the whole thing but he was like
yeah uh so we're
we've heard about this uh case that's
been going around where people are uh
picking up credit cards of uh people and
uh using them without their permission
so uh i need you to like open your
wallet and uh i need to see some
identification and i need to see the
names on your credit cards
and at first i was like
what the [ __ ] is this like scam [ __ ]
that sounds like the most sus like
[ __ ] story
so i like the wallet inspector
ever i was like uh can i see your
identification please
because i wasn't too sure right yeah i
was like i need to make sure this guy's
a cop yes i was like can i see your
identification he looked at me like what
do you mean i'm i'm obviously dressed up
as a cop and i'm like no no i need to
say like your badge so he showed me his
badge i was like okay looks fine game
gave me the wallet he saw my japanese
name on my credit card yeah and he was
like oh nihonjin
and i was like yes immediately gives me
back my wallet
and he was like oh dad's over there have
a good day sorry i thought you're a
thought
yeah so basically yeah he saw my
japanese name
was like oh you [ __ ] you're japanese
whoops my bad here's your wallet back
have a good day it just went off and
then i and i stopped and just kind of
hid away to just see if he would stop
anyone else for like five minutes he
didn't stop anyone else he was just
walking around he was probably waiting
for the next foreigner so i was like
what if he'd been connor had been shot
yeah he's just teased on the spot oh my
god
you know it's also really annoying about
uh i guess just cops and security people
in japan is that you cannot tell the
difference by looking from a security
guard in a cop in japan they all dress
the same all the building like managers
and stuff also dressed like military
forces
really because like every mall i've been
to the security guard is like an 80 year
old dude really yeah dude and i'm like
what are you guarding you go into some
buildings and the security are dressed
like they're going to
and it's like where are you going i
don't know just everywhere i go they're
all dressed in like these military
outfits it's so weird maybe i like the
embassies and [ __ ] no no i've never been
to an embassy in japan
all the serious security guys i've seen
are like yeah all decrepit yeah they're
like they're like 60 70 year old dudes
with like hats and they're like yeah
where the hell do you go yeah yeah
it's like the two places uh japanese
businessmen retire like like taxi
drivers and taxi drivers right that's
what i thought yeah services that can
put people's lives in danger
i i look at these like 70 year old like
security guards and i'm like okay let's
say hypothetically i like you know what
another steal some [ __ ] what are you
gonna do well the security guards in
japan are there to call the police yeah
basically yeah they do yeah they're not
actually going to hate you
i've never seen a secret just act like a
civilian right yeah i mean you know
you or you have that they call up the
the group of 15 cops
no but it was shocking because i've
never been stopped by like a cop before
i never been stuck like that that's the
first time i've ever stopped i've never
been stopped that was the first time
ever i've been stopped twice have you
[ __ ] hilarious i don't know you do
look a bit sort of dodgy though
i look at you and i think that man needs
to be arrested
and
he's done some [ __ ] throw the key away
[Laughter]
when in shinjuku presumably or something
i wanted um one of the old studio right
one of the old studios yeah police came
in
please stop everything
stop this recording is there a mr cohen
in here
and one at like
around like
at that area what did you what have you
done what'd you do nothing
what did i do like i pushed on the phone
confess now no i was walking and i i i
was again i was there you were alone
yeah
i saw a bunch of dudes walk past and the
stooges parked up when he saw me and
just like came over to me and just
stopped me and asked for my like id and
all that
and i was like i was like
nothing i just gave him it i was like
what do you want i could i could clearly
see that he was a police officer and i
was like all right well i guess i'll
show it to you and i was just bantering
and stuff and he told me about his
favorite games and [ __ ] it was weird it
was fun i was telling him that my train
was leaving in two minutes and he kind
of he hurried up it's interesting
because that experience sounds really
wrong right the whole sort of he just
stops yeah nothing because you'll just
but then he was nice so it was kind of
like really concerned he was nice you
know i don't understand why he i wish
that there was an explanation even if he
tried to explain to me i wouldn't
understand anyway but it didn't really
seem like he tried to explain why he was
stopping me he just stopped me and was
like i did please i mean he gave me an
explanation and just sounded like a scam
oh dude just straight up just like id
guys i do card you just wanted my
residence card yeah i was like
one you assume i have
urgent cards which i do or maybe i
didn't maybe that's the important point
you always need to carry a residence
card if you live in japan if you if you
get caught without it you can get fined
like a hundred thousand yen yeah yeah
like that like when we have to send our
um residence card off to get renewed for
our visa which you know before happened
to be like every six months because we
couldn't get a visa beyond six months
that that like few weeks in between us
waiting to get our god yeah residence
card like that was just like yours
or something no because we have to send
off our passport as well oh jesus so the
only thing we had was a little bit of
paper said
that says that uh there's not even like
a document it's an email that says oh
they've sent it off and they're getting
it renewed and uh
i don't know how uh i don't know how
friendly the cops would be if you just
open up this email they're pretty they'd
be pretty understanding i think that
just yeah i don't know i think it's just
that first hurdle they have to get right
because like i don't have i don't have
his idea card so yeah every time i'm
like uh i don't have a zeity card like i
was like ready to like write the ticket
he's like you don't have this
then i have to explain yeah
ten thousand dollars gone yeah it's all
right i mean i don't really get too
offended about it it's a bit annoying
but i i wish they would just tell me why
they're doing it
random random stop and search yeah
random random yeah
[Music]
yeah because like i've never seen a cop
do that with a japanese person like the
only time i've ever seen he's talking to
jack told me but i don't look japanese
so literally the only thing i've ever
seen cops talking to japanese people are
like when someone's shouting or there's
been a car accident i've ever seen yeah
like when there's an actual i don't know
if i'm just being biased i could totally
be being like anecdotal evidence here
being completely biased i mean that's
usually what it is like when there's an
actual problem then the cops get
involved but when it's just a white guy
walking down the street apparently it's
like oops i do card time no it's never
happened to me and the police i met have
been always very nice and friends yeah
yeah like i said like they're all nice
they're all nice yeah i told the guy i
wanted to get my train in two minutes
and he kind of hurried up yeah that's
good i was like can't i need to get that
one and he was like oh i'll do my sense
i got stopped for speeding once i was
going like four kilometers per hour over
the limit and it was one of the way
situations where i just saw you see i
was going four
they were stopping everyone they were
just stopping all the cars and because
everyone just in the countryside goes
over the limit a little bit yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because the speed limit
is so low it is very low here and they
apologize for pulling me over there oh
my god we're so sorry we're so sorry we
know this is ridiculous
we're so sorry to inform you that you're
breaking the wall
they kind of knew it was a bit petty and
i sort of they could be doing something
they give you points yeah i got a few
points for that
a lot of people do go like 110 on the
like 70 or 80 miles yeah because the
highway is like 80. yeah so the mass
prior is like what 50 maximum 50 miles
per hour on the highways you're not
getting anywhere 50 miles an hour i get
it's a small country but you know people
got to go well you know to the uk it's
not a small country that's why like you
know you're not surprised when you're
seeing like there would be like cars
tons of them just getting like 110 yeah
yeah yeah
all of them do it none of them follow
the rules
but apparently i was told i don't know
if this is true it's the person in front
who gets the blame if everyone's like
speeding behind a leader yeah whoever
because the leader is clearly the one
the insider
influenced them i don't know how true
that is i imagine if like 20 people are
speeding they can't stop every car yeah
you've got to set an example right
that's what i mean if
i've noticed that whenever like one car
goes in in the front yeah the other cars
just go back in yeah yeah
they don't want to be the one in the
front yeah
that could be just make sense yeah i
don't know if it could be just
completely
hysterical it makes sense but
i don't know realize i've been looking
at the wrong camera the entire time
looking at this one
oh my god you've been on this show
four times now chris oh my god that's a
good way to end it chris look at the
wrong camera chris looking at the wrong
camera the whole episode thank you chris
just punch in 400 percent digital all
right
chris yeah always a blast only your
fourth time here and you uh can't look
at the right camera yeah yeah
maybe first time yeah maybe fifth time
yeah fifth time what's the direct
cinematography well at least i am
affable and that is the main takeaway
from this episode thank you for having
me you know who else is
our patrons
on screen right now look at them
of course absolutely
oh i love that name yeah that one's
really good as well actually
[Music]
thank you for having me on i hope to see
you again please let me back
you will be back come on bungee jumping
chris
you're going to be a lot of fun into a
river let's get it done what take it for
granted
if we die it is it's in good mood it's a
river if we die do we at least get it in
8k you will be cgi'd in future episodes
your estates
they will have c dog connor cgi connor
ai i don't permit this at all but hey if
you'd like to be affable and support the
show then make sure to go over to our
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
twitter send us some views on the
subreddit
subscribe
and subscribe
this guy already yeah
your
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us
bye
[Music]
you